>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, D.C.
>> Susan Vita: Good
morning, everyone.
As one of my colleagues said,
"Monday morning,
early in December.
Is anyone going to come?"
So it's really fabulous
to see every --
all of these seats filled,
and so much just excitement
from the conversations
that are going on.
I think this is -- bodes well
for what we're going
to do today.
And I wanted to welcome you
to the Library of Congress.
You are the perfect
audience, patrons and lovers
of the arts and the humanities.
And this is the oldest
cultural institution
in the entire country.
And so I think it's a
perfect venue for a spotlight
on arts education symposium.
I am pleased to recognize the
District of Columbia Commission
on Arts and Education.
I am pleased to --
sorry, to recognize the --
it for its work developing
and promoting local artists
and organizations,
providing grants, programs,
education activities
that encourage diverse,
artistic expression, and
learning opportunities
for all District of Columbia
residents and visitors
to experience the rich
culture of our city.
The Library of Congress,
as I said,
is the oldest cultural
institution in the country.
It's more than two
centuries old,
and I thought I would tell
you a few things about it,
and why it's a good place
to have this symposium.
It features 883 miles
of shelving,
houses 155 million total items.
It holds 33 million
books written
in 460 different languages.
It's home to 68 million
manuscripts, 25 million pieces
of music, more than
5 million maps,
over 3.4 million recordings,
and more than 13.5
million photographs.
We receive and add
approximately 12,000 items
to our collection every day.
And -- so basically, what I am
-- why I'm telling you this is,
I'm trying to emphasize the fact
that people say library books.
Well, forget that.
We do have much more than books,
and so many of these things
can be used by the people
that you're helping
to inspire artistic
and expression in
the humanities.
Here's -- this is just a
whirlwind listing of a sample
of what you could
encourage people to use.
Children's books -- we have
the smallest children's books.
It's "Old King Cole."
It is about the size
of a period.
And we have the largest book.
It is a five-by-seven book
featuring color images
of Bhutan.
So it's -- imagine that it's
as tall as I am, and I'm not --
it's a lot wider
than I am, thank God.
The oldest written material
in the library is a
cuneiform tablet dating
from 2040 B.C. Comic books --
we have the world's largest
collection of comic books,
more than 140,000 of them.
And we also hold the
world's most extensive
newspaper collection.
The oldest original newspaper
is from December 29th, 1659.
We have the papers
of 23 presidents.
Before people started putting
them in their own buildings,
we -- this is the
place where they came.
So we have George Washington --
everything from George
Washington
up through Calvin Coolidge.
We have the Gutenberg
Bible, which is one
of three perfect vellum
copies in the world.
More than 50 million
visual materials,
including the most comprehensive
international collection
of posters in the world.
And the most comprehensive
visual record
of the Civil War -- can you
imagine how important the Civil
War is, in humanities and the
arts, and fact that we have all
of this material on the
Civil War, of photographs,
and band music, and
all sorts of things?
The Library's Packard Campus
for Audiovisual Conservation
in Culpepper has 60 -- sorry,
6 million items, including more
than 3.6 million sound
recordings, and more --
almost 2 million films.
And the most comprehensive
collection --
I'm the chief of the -- I
forgot to introduce myself.
I'm Susan Vita, the Chief
of the Music Division here
at the Library of Congress.
So let me say a couple things
about the music collection.
We have more than 25 -- it's
the largest music collection
in the world.
We have more than
25 million items,
including 8 million
pieces of sheet music,
which include all sorts of --
you can really learn a
lot of things about --
when you just look
at sheet music.
Basically, what ads
were people --
you know, were important
in that time?
What were the clothes
that people were
wearing, from the covers?
We have -- they depict the
sinking of the Titanic,
and the Triangle Shirtwaist
Fire, 400 songs about baseball,
more than 13,000
World War I songs.
The collection includes
an extensive assemblage
of original manuscripts
by composers
of the American musical theater,
and the largest collection
of any one kind of musical
instrument in the world,
and that is the flute.
So let me just talk a second
about the musical theater,
and the connections, and
how you can use the Library.
If you, for example, were going
to encourage somebody to look
at "On The Town," we have
Leonard Bernstein's collection.
He's going to be --
everybody's going
to be celebrating his
100th anniversary in --
starting at the end
of this year,
but next year, particularly.
And so we have his collection.
So you could see music in
his hand here, and also,
we have Oliver Smith's
collection.
Oliver Smith was -- this
is from "On The Town."
This is -- we have his original
drawings of sets, and this is --
I mean, when -- might be more
fun to be here right now.
This is the -- it looks like
it's Coney Island, right?
So anyway, we have
things that link,
and that shows people how
you can use original source
material, and get ideas
about other things.
The archive of folk culture
is the largest repository
of traditional cultural
documentation,
and one of the largest
in the world.
It contains the largest
collection
of American Indian
music and spoken word,
and the earliest ethnographic
field recordings made anywhere
in the world.
Veterans history collects
the stories of veterans,
and to date, more than
100,000 of them are here.
The Story Corps Project is a
nationwide grassroots initiative
to record the oral
histories of people like you
and me, ordinary citizens.
How many stories
are probably buried
in the Story Corps archives?
I just -- since 1931, the
Library has provided books
to the blind in Braille,
and now on sound recordings,
the talking books and
digital playback equipment.
And we have the world's
largest collection
of cartographic materials,
more than 5-1/2 million items.
And one of the really
interesting parts of that is,
it's got the largest collection
of fire insurance maps of cities
and towns in the United States,
and they are amazing
just to look at them.
They're very easy --
they're big-enough scale
so that they're easy to read.
You can go back and see where
your grandfather was, you know,
born, and lived, and
that kind of thing.
It's just very interesting.
So basically, you can kind of
tell that I'm pretty much in awe
of the embarrassment of
riches that we have here.
And the only thing that
is disappointing is
that it's not used enough.
So I'm encouraging all of you
to think about that as you go
about your own studies,
and creations,
and also as you encourage
the people
that you serve to do the same.
And now, it is my pleasure
to introduce Rhona Wolfe
Friedman, from the commission.
Her passion for the
promotion of the arts
and humanities is the reason why
this symposium has come about.
And if you know Rhona, you know
that she's a very difficult
person to say no to.
And she will throw herself
into producing the best
possible program to motivate you
to go out and do good.
So get ready for a
wonderful experience,
because Rhona planned it.
Rhona?
[ Applause ]
>> Rhona Wolfe Friedman:
Good morning.
It's wonderful to be here
in the Montpelier Room
on the sixth floor at
the Library of Congress.
The commission is delighted
to partner with the Library
to present this arts
education symposium.
The symposium would not
have happened, though,
without the vision and
efforts of Susan Vita,
the woman you just heard,
the Chief of the Library's Music
Division, and Lee Ann Potter,
sitting up front, the Director
of Educational Outreach
for the Library.
Lee Ann worked diligently
for months
to make sure this
symposium would take place.
Thank you to both.
[ Applause ]
And a special thank-you to
commission staff, Jeffrey Scott
and David Markey,
who were great help
with organization and logistics.
I'd also like to
recognize Arthur Espinoza,
our executive director,
and Kay Kendall,
the chair of our commission.
I'm now honored to
introduce Jane Chu.
Jane Chu is the Chairman of the
National Endowment for the Arts.
She has a background in arts
administration, philanthropy,
and is an accomplished
artist and musician.
Jane is the daughter of Chinese
immigrants, born in Oklahoma
and raised in Arkansas.
She's a pianist with
undergraduate
and graduate degrees
in music and piano.
Ms. Chu also holds
a master's degree
in business administration,
a Ph.D.,
and three honorary degrees.
She has vast experience
in arts education,
and arts administration.
Prior to coming to the NEA,
Ms. Chu served as the president
and CEO of the Kaufmann
Center for the Performing Arts
in Kansas City, Missouri.
At the NEA, under
Ms. Chu's guidance,
the NEA has awarded more
than $377 million in grants
to nonprofit organizations
and artists.
Also, Ms. Chu launched the
United States of Arts Project
that demonstrates the
importance of the arts
in our communities and lives.
In 2015, Ms. Chu launched
her signature initiative,
Creativity Connects, to
investigate the current state
of the arts in our nation, and
explore how the arts connect
with other industries.
It is no wonder that under
Ms. Chu's leadership,
the NEA ranks first among small
agencies for the best places
to work in the federal
government in 2016.
With great honor and
pleasure, I welcome Jane Chu.
[ Applause ]
>> Jane Chu: Thank you so much.
It's really wonderful
to be here.
Thank you, and I want to
thank the Library of Congress
and the D.C. Commission
on the Arts and Humanities
for inviting me to speak today.
Arts education is a topic
that's very dear to my heart,
and it's not just because I
majored in music, or I majored
in arts education, specifically
music education, in college.
But it's because I have
known about the power
of what the arts
can do for students,
that not only honors the
appreciate of art, but it spills
over into so many areas
of our daily lives.
My father was a college
professor, not in music,
but when he died when I was
nine, it was the piano lessons
that I was taking as
a kid that soothed me.
It was music that helped me
express myself beyond the use
of just linear, everyday
conversations,
and as a nine-year-old, I really
didn't have the full vocabulary
to be able to express my grief
over the loss of a parent.
And perhaps many
nine-year-olds don't have that.
But I didn't have enough
words, since my parents,
who were from China, spoke
Mandarin at home, and I,
who was born in Oklahoma
and grew up in Arkansas,
spoke English at school.
But the arts were there for me.
So throughout my whole
growing-up years, I participated
in as many arts activities as
I could find, from music camps,
and singing in choirs,
and acting in theater
productions,
to drawing every day.
And to this day, as an adult,
I still draw every day.
So through my growing-up years,
I became intellectually
interested in it, to the point
where I majored in
music in college.
So participating in the arts
gave me another vocabulary set.
It's another language
that allowed me
to express what I felt.
Playing the piano soothed me.
It became my refuge.
Drawing allowed me to create,
and also live in the moment,
where I was so immersed
in the creative process
that time stood still.
The arts helped me navigate
through those bok choy corndog
moments, because I had the power
to be able to make each
of us feel like we belong.
That's what the arts do, even
when we're standing in the midst
of living with multiple
perspectives,
and different opinions.
The arts give us tools
for self-expression
when words alone are not enough.
They help channel our
emotions, no matter how messy
or confusing, into
something beautiful,
rather than something
destructive.
The arts help to empower us
to imagine new possibilities
for what we might achieve.
So everybody who
has participated
in the arts has likely
experienced these effects,
and all of you, I'm sure, have.
But there is a growing body of
research about arts education
that confirms what we
instinctively know,
that children and
teenagers who participated
in arts education
programs were associated
with more positive academic and
social outcomes than students
who did not participate
in those programs.
And this was especially true for
youth who came from households
with very few social or
economic opportunities.
Eighth graders from
low socioeconomic homes
who were active in the arts
in elementary school showed
higher test scores in science
and writing than students who
were not active in the arts.
High schoolers from
low socioeconomic homes
who were active in the
arts were more likely
to complete a calculus
course than students
with no arts-rich experiences.
And across the board,
arts-engaged students showed
higher overall grade point
averages, and these higher GPAs
were found with all students
who participated in the arts,
regardless of where
students came from,
regardless if they came
from low socioeconomic homes
or high socioeconomic
homes, versus students
who did not participate
in the arts.
And high school students
who earned few
to no arts credits
were associated
with being five times more
likely not to have graduated
than students who
earned many arts credits.
The arts-rich students in high
school were more likely to go
to college, more likely to
enroll in four-year colleges,
more likely to get
a bachelor's degree,
more likely to earn
mostly As in college,
more likely to involve
themselves in the community.
More likely to read the
newspaper at least once --
or one time in the day,
more likely to participate
in student government and
service clubs, volunteer, vote,
especially those from low
socioeconomic backgrounds.
And by the way, you can
find all of this research,
along with hundreds of other
arts education studies,
online at artsedsearch.org,
and today, I'm drawing mostly
from the work of
Dr. James Catterall.
But you get the idea.
There's a very strong
relationship between children
and teens who have high
levels of arts engagement
and positive outcomes for
their lives, versus those
with low levels of arts
engagement, especially those
who are challenged with fewer
social and economic resources.
So what this means is that,
by closing the gaps in terms
of who has access to arts
education and who does not,
we're also helping to close
the broader achievement gaps
that exist in our
educational system.
So if we're serious about
evening the playing field
for youth who come from low
socioeconomic households,
then we need to get serious
about providing equal
access to the arts.
Because the arts are not a
matter of, it's nice to have,
but only if there's
room in the budget.
They are a necessity that's
going to help all children
across the United States
reach their full potential
in their every moments, and
for their successful futures.
I know that the D.C.
Commission on the Arts
and Humanities understands this,
and I want to applaud
their efforts
to bring the arts to
all D.C. students.
Because the D.C. Commission
is one of the main supporters
of the D.C. Arts and Humanities
Education Collaborative,
and this Collaborative
is the newest member
of the Kennedy Center's
Any Given Child Program.
It's the first member to
span grades K through 12,
to help communities expand
access to arts education,
and we're really looking forward
to seeing the results here
in Washington, D.C. Because
this program is going to work
in tandem with a
collective impact grant
from the National
Endowment for the Arts,
and part of this work brings
together parents, and teachers,
students, administrators,
along with the D.C. Commission
and the Kennedy Center.
To develop an arts education
agenda for Washington, D.C.,
as well as specific
measurable goals
for how the agenda
will be achieved.
We envision a day when all
communities make arts education
a priority, just
as D.C. is doing.
And over the past five
decades, the National Endowment
for the Arts has
invested 244 million
in arts education projects
across the United States,
and these projects range
from in-school performances
and artist residencies.
Afterschool arts
programs for students,
professional development
for teachers,
collective impact projects such
as the one I've just mentioned
with the D.C. Arts
and Humanities Education
Collaborative collective
impact group.
We must thrive, and we must
strive to empower every child
in this country with an
excellent arts education.
Forty percent of our arts
education grants are awarded
to organizations in
high-poverty communities,
and we're also launching a
statewide data infrastructure
project in every single
state that helps identify
which communities have fewer
arts education opportunities
for students, so
we can help there.
And this is in cooperative
with the education
commission of the states.
So you get the idea.
We believe it's a big
job, and I do want
to introduce Ayanna Hudson.
Ayanna, would you stand?
Ayanna's our Director
of Arts Education.
And if you have any questions --
[ Applause ]
-- yes, she deserves
that applause.
If you have questions about arts
education, or grants related
to that, e-mail Ayanna,
and she will guide you
through that process.
You can e-mail her at three
in the morning if you want to,
and she'll -- you're welcome.
She will -- oh, and
there's Nancy Daugherty.
Didn't see Nancy.
Nancy also, please
stand as well.
Our -- we have a wonderful team,
and so feel free to connect
with them throughout the day,
because they're here for you.
This is a big job.
Providing equal access to
the arts requires input
at every level -- parents,
teachers, local, state,
national leaders,
principals, superintendents,
and so I'm hopeful that
we're going to reach a day
where the country embraces
the arts as a fundamental
and indispensable part of
our children's success.
Because arts education
is not about --
just about children learning how
to finger a B flat on a trumpet.
That might be nice, but it's
not just about learning how
to pirouette, although
that might be nice.
Or teaching children
how to use watercolors
to paint a picture of a tree.
That might be nice.
Arts education is about giving
students a tool belt of skills
that allow them to reach
their full potential,
where children can achieve
academically and socially,
and where they can imagine a
world beyond what they might
know, and dream of new
possibilities for themselves,
and where they can express their
ideas beyond the use of linear,
everyday conversations.
And they can develop
self-confidence, and discover
that they really do belong,
and communicate with others,
and reach those who have
perspectives different
from their own, and
innovate, and create.
Because we know that whenever
we create, we move away
from being stuck, and we open
the door to solving those old
and tired problems in new, and
positive, and meaningful ways.
The United States has always
been a nation of innovators
and visionaries, and
instilling the arts
in our students will help ensure
that this legacy
remains in place.
So I want to thank
everybody here today
for recognizing the
importance of arts education,
and for working so hard to
ensure a promising future
for all of our children.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Rhona Wolfe Friedman:
Thank you, Jane,
for a very inspiring
and lovely speech.
I'd like to now -- to start
us off with our first panel.
Our introduction to this
will be Arthur Espinoza,
the Executive Director
of the D.C. Commission
in the Arts and Humanities.
[ Applause ]
>> Arthur Espinoza:
Good morning.
>> Good morning.
>> Arthur Espinoza: It's Monday,
and there's so many
beautiful people in the room,
all gathered for one great idea.
I'm so excited about this.
As we said before, we
weren't really sure
if this would fill up, and
I'm so excited that it has.
So thank you, and
welcome to all of you,
on behalf of the Commission
on the Arts and Humanities.
And I certainly want to
thank our colleagues here
from the Library of
Congress for their help.
We appreciate your
coordination in this event.
In particular, Susan
Vita, and Lee Ann Potter,
as we've recognized
before, thank you so much.
Much appreciated.
If there's any standing
room over there --
I'll do a little housekeeping.
There's some extra seating
back over here, as well,
so I want to make sure that
everybody is comfortable,
can see, and can hear clearly.
We're in for a lot today,
and we hope that you'll
find good things out of it.
I'd also like to thank the
Library of Congress for opening
up what is the -- a
little bit of information
about the treasure
chest of this building.
It is just amazing to hear Ms.
Vita talk about all the things
that one can access here, which
I think we all know about,
but we forget about sometimes,
or we don't always have time.
So I do ask that you all
consider your opportunities
there, and how that may be
able to help inform your work.
I'd like to recognize, as we
did already, Chair Kay Kendall.
She's the chair of
the commission.
If you don't mind standing,
just so everybody can see you --
also, Gretchen Wharton,
one of our commissioners,
and Haili Francis.
And if I missed any
commissioner,
I hope you'll forgive
me, but welcome.
We're glad to have you here.
Thanks also to the staff,
as we mentioned before.
Dr. Jeffrey Scott, David Markey,
and Inissa Salei
[assumed spelling]
in our arts education
department, thank you all
for your hard work on today,
and putting it together.
And of course, thanks
to Dr. Jane Chu.
Those remarks were really
inspiring and wonderful,
and thank you for being here,
and leading us with your work
at the National Endowment
for the Arts.
And it's really an honor
to work alongside them.
As a state arts agency, we have
this opportunity to partner
with the NEA to carry out their
initiative, along with our own,
and we're really
pleased to work with them
and all the staff from the NEA.
They're always such great
partners to work with,
so welcome to all of you
that are here from the NEA.
I think I saw a few, but I
know there's probably others,
and great to see you.
I also want to repeat a little
bit about what Dr. Chu said.
I think you heard very well
the value of arts education,
and the value of how that starts
to change our society
and our community.
We know these things
that are critical
to what we're doing
are really critical
to the communities
that we live in.
And they're also, to
business, very valuable.
Things such as creative
thinking, and critical skills
that you have to help
inform your work,
whether you stay
in the arts or not.
Now, we hope that everyone
here continues to have
that lifelong experience
with the arts,
but we know that it also
helps bring valuable skills
to teamwork.
And in a workplace,
in a business setting,
that's a really valuable
asset for us to have.
And the arts help us learn that.
We're going to hope that
today is going to provide you
with a lot of information
about how you can move forward
with your own practice.
Whether you're interested
in trying to find ways
to empower students, or
whether that's simply the work
that you're doing to find
equitable participation
in the schools, and help us
break down those barriers
that exist within the
communities that we all live in.
We know these are important
aspects that we want to address,
and the arts really
do help us do that.
Of course, student success
and achievement is critical,
and it's also critical
for our mayor.
Mayor Bowser, here in
the District of Columbia,
has been very supportive of
the efforts that we carry out,
and that you all carry
out, in arts education.
I want to thank her for
her continued support
of the commission, and
for her continued support,
especially, of arts education.
We appreciate all that
she's doing to support us.
I do hope that they'll be some
great insights, and we're going
to get going now
with our first panel.
There's been a lot of
talking, and so now we're ready
to start listening to others,
who are going to invite us
to think a little
bit more deeply.
Helping us do that is our
special guest, and our moderator
for our first panel, Senior
Vice President for Education
at the John F. Kennedy Center
for the Performing
Arts, Mario Rossero.
I don't say that very often.
You know that?
You probably say
it all the time.
[ Applause ]
>> Mario Rossero: Good
morning, everyone.
>> Morning.
>> Mario Rossero: It's
great to join you.
I feel like this is always one
of those arts education
family reunion moments.
I have one of the best
jobs in the world.
I get to lead all the education
efforts at the Kennedy Center
for the Performing Arts,
which is both local,
regional, and national.
I am inspired by my colleagues
who've done such a great job
to set the table, I think, for
today's conversation, but first,
I just wanted to thank
Rhona and the commission
for the invitation to
join everyone today.
So you may or may not know
that this past May was the 100th
birthday of President Kennedy.
And so, for the Kennedy
Center, many know us
for the world-class
performing arts on our stages,
but we also uplift the ideals
from President Kennedy's legacy
of service, justice, freedom,
courage, and gratitude
through the arts,
through the memorial
that the building
really is to him.
But, you know, the Kennedy
Center's really more
than just a building,
or an address.
It's also this idea,
and it's an ideal
that the arts are
really for everyone.
And so, as the nation's
cultural center,
we really feel a responsibility
on our shoulders to make sure
that we're fighting alongside
all of our colleagues
in this room, to make
sure that those barriers
to access are removed, and
that the highest-quality arts
and arts education experiences
are available to all.
And so, it's my team's
charge to really make sure
that we lock arms with
our colleagues here
and across the country, and we
take a lot of time to identify
and know what the problems
and challenges in the field
of arts education and arts
learning are, as well as some
of the best practices.
And we're really lucky to
have the support and resources
to create some model programs
that can try out some solutions
to those problems, right?
Because everybody in this
room, we stand on the shoulders
of a history of work and effort
to really tackle
this problem, right?
And I always like to acknowledge
everyone who's spent the last
20, 30, 40, 50 years
really working at this,
and I think it takes everyone
working together in lockstep
to address these arts
education challenges, right?
And it's really a cross-sectoral
challenge, but I am inspired
and excited that we
can do it together.
And I think the voices
that we're going to hear
from today give us a
range of perspectives.
And what we're going to hear
about is not just about equity,
access, and innovation in
the arts, and arts education,
but it's also rooted in some
exemplars, some best practices,
really looking at the
evidence, and some demonstration
of the power of the arts.
So if you'd join me in
some round of applause,
I'm going to welcome our
panelists up to the stage.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit, and buy them some time
as they make their way up,
but we can maybe have a
continuous round of applause.
First we have Dr.
Alexander Panteyat,
who's joining us
from Johns Hopkins.
So Alex, come on up.
We have Christopher K.
Morgan from Dance Place,
local arts organization, my
good friend Nathan Diamond
from D.C. Public Schools,
who leads the arts charge
for the district, and
we have Asha Gardner,
from Split This Rock.
[ Applause ]
So before we jump into our
conversation on innovation,
access and equity in the
arts, we always believe
that it is a good idea to
start with the arts, right?
So we're thrilled that Alex was
willing to play a piece for us.
So we're going to start
with a piece of music.
This is "Meditation"
from the opera, "Thais."
Take it away.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
What a beautiful piece.
So before we get started,
just a couple logistics.
My goal is to really
have a great conversation
with everyone, but
leave time at the end
for some audience questions.
So as you listen, think
about anything that might be
on your mind that you want
to go a little bit deeper in.
So please consider that.
Also, everyone's bios are
in your program books,
so you might go a little bit
deeper to find out about folks.
And I was also asked to make
sure everyone has their cell
phones on silent, just before
we start our conversation,
so thank you for that.
So Alex, I'm going
to start with you.
Thank you so much for
that beautiful piece,
and for sharing your
artistic talents as well.
But we love this idea
about especially the arts
and sciences overlapping,
and we actually find a lot
of connections between
all the art forms
and health and wellness.
But I know you've got a
particular interest and focus
in music and wellness
and health.
So I wonder if you might give
us a little bit of context
about your work, and
some of the findings,
and things you're finding
interesting right now
in your work.
>> Dr. Alexander Panteyat:
Thank you very much
on the introduction, Mario.
It's my pleasure to
be here this morning
in front of this full room.
I do have a sense that I'm
preaching to the choir,
but it's nevertheless
very important.
As I think you could tell, music
is very near and dear to me.
For my patients'
sake at this point,
I hope I'm a much better
physician than I am a musician.
But I've been playing the
violin since I was seven,
and so exposure to
music education,
including in public school,
in elementary school --
I still remember
my orchestra days,
playing "William Tell Overture."
I think it's played a -- I would
say a central role in my life,
but what I want to say
a few words about now is
that the research
over the last five
to seven years has
actually provided evidence
for the importance
of music education.
And it's linked to success
throughout the lifetime
of a person, and particularly
academic achievement.
So there was a hypothesis put
forth by Dr. Aniruddh Patel
from Tufts University, and
published in "Frontiers
of Psychology" in 2011,
and it's easy to remember,
because the acronym of
the hypothesis is OPERA.
And that really, I think, sets
up a useful framework for some
of the research that
has been done
in the last five to six years.
The OPERA hypothesis
proposes that benefits --
possible benefits of music
are driven by plasticity
in the speech processing
parts of the brain,
and brain networks for speech.
And this plasticity occurs
when five conditions are met,
and so that's the acronym.
And they are O for overlap, P
for precision, E for emotion,
R for repetition,
and A for attention.
There is anatomical overlap
in the brain networks
that process sound features
used in both music and speech.
For example, the amplitude
of the sound waves,
as well as the periodicity with
which the sound waves appear.
P stands for precision.
Music places higher demands
on these shared networks
when compared to speech
-- the demands of speech,
in terms of how precise
the timing needs to be.
E, for emotion -- the
musical activities
that engage this network can
elicit very strong emotions.
I don't know how many of
you have had the experience
of feeling chills, or
shivers up and down your spine
when you're listening to a
pleasurable piece of music.
And of course, one
size does not fit all.
It's very individual,
but we can agree that --
and it's been scientifically
demonstrated
in the last six years or so
that powerful emotional
centers are activated
when we're listening to music.
R stands for repetition.
The musical activities that
engage this network connected
to speech are frequently
repeated as we're listening,
and as we're practicing
an instrument or singing.
And that repetition
is crucial to success.
And finally, A for attention.
Musical activities that
engage the network I'm talking
about are associated
with focused attention,
and of course, you
have to pay attention
as we're learning a
musical instrument.
So according to the
OPERA hypothesis,
when these conditions
are met, neuroplasticity,
long-term changes in the
brain drives these networks
to function with higher
precision than is needed
for ordinary speech
communication.
However, since speech shares
these networks with music,
speech benefits in
a secondary way,
the processing of speech itself.
And so the OPERA hypothesis
has been used to account
for superior encoding of speech
in musically-trained
individuals,
which I won't have time to
go into in detail today,
but I'm happy to
answer questions about.
And this suggests mechanisms
by which musical training
could improve the linguistic
reading abilities.
So I'm just going to run
through literally the headlines
of studies published in
the last five, six years,
and there's one particularly
relevant study by Nina Kraus
from Northwestern
University in Chicago,
which I think is inspiring,
that I want to focus
on for a couple of minutes.
So thus far, studies
have shown that babies --
one-year-olds who have music
lessons with their parents tend
to smile more and earlier,
and communicate better.
Music training can improve
white matter connectivity.
The highways in our brain
that connect the thinking,
gray matter areas, and enable
rapid millisecond-level
processing, they are
actually strengthened
as a result of musical training.
Not just listening.
It needs to be active musical
training participation.
So I could go into details
if you're interested,
as far as how long it takes.
It's not immediate, you know,
but after as little as one year,
sometimes -- one
year to 15 months,
the musical training changes
are seen in the brain.
Where are the changes seen?
Well, the corpus callosum,
which is the main white matter
highway connecting the two
hemispheres, the two
halves of the brain,
that's actually made thicker,
strengthened as a result
of musical training over time.
And, the arcuate fasciculus,
which on the left side
of the brain for most people,
serves as the main connection
between the areas
understanding language
and producing language
in the brain as well.
Blood flow in the brain in some
of those speech areas
I mentioned
in the OPERA hypothesis
is increased,
real-time practically,
as a result of musical
training and exposure.
Executive function, going from
point A, to point B, to point C,
multi-tasking, so
crucial in our world --
that actually improves
as a result
of musical training over time.
The gray matter -- not
just the white matter.
Certain areas in the cortex,
the outer part of the brain,
are actually made
bigger as a result
of musical training
and exposure.
Verbal memory and childhood
literacy is actually improved
over time as a result of classes
exposing people to music.
And this was not just for kids.
Over the course of our
lifetime, as we age,
there is now several
studies that show
that the brain plasticity
is benefitted
by musical training
throughout the lifetime.
And in fact, this is now
beginning to be thought
as a protective measure,
playing a musical instrument,
against cognitive aging,
mild cognitive impairment,
dementia of the Alzheimer's
type and others.
But what I want to just
emphasize a little bit more --
that's Dr. Nina Kraus's
work that I mentioned --
is that it actually may --
musical training in school may
actually help reduce academic
achievement gaps.
An August 2014 report from
the American Psychological
Association stated that learning
to play a musical instrument
or to sing can help
disadvantaged children
strengthen their reading
and language skills,
which may reduce
academic achievement gaps.
These findings involved hundreds
of children participating
in musical training
programs in both Chicago
and Los Angeles public schools.
The positive role that
musical training can have
for youth living in impoverished
areas was presented by Dr. Kraus
in 2014, at the American
Psychological Association's
annual convention.
Kraus's research concluded
that musical training can
enhance the way children's
nervous systems process sounds
in busy or chaotic environments,
like a classroom,
or a playground.
After just two years
of musical training --
not one, because she looked
at one and also two years.
After two years of
musical training,
the children's brain
responses to sounds were faster
and more precise than in
students who had other types
of enrichment classes.
So this was not just
a comparison
of music classes to nothing.
The improved neural
function caused
by music training may
lead to enhanced memory
and attention span, which in
turn can make it easier for kids
to stay focused in the classroom
and improve their
communication skills.
Other separate studies
over the last five
to six years have shown
that arithmetic performance,
achievement in verbal
skills, language learning,
and even second, foreign
language acquisition,
which I would argue is
increasingly important
in our globalized world.
That actually can be
made easier by music.
You heard before that music
is a language all its own.
Well, there's actually
now neural --
anatomical neurobiological
truth to that.
And we know that with each
additional language acquired,
it becomes easier to acquire
the subsequent language,
even if it's not
connected in any way
to the languages
you already know.
So research has shown that there
are differences in the brains
of children raised in
impoverished environments
that affect their
ability to learn.
While more affluent students
do better in school than kids
from lower-income backgrounds,
we are starting to find
that musical training can
alter the nervous system
to create a better learner and
help offset this academic gap.
And so I'm happy to talk
more, but I want to make sure
that other panelists
have enough time.
So I just want to conclude by
saying that evidence is mounting
that musical training
boosts brain power
and cognitive function
in children and adults.
Neural enhancements
that are gained
through musical training early
in life can extend throughout
the lifespan and into old age.
And hopefully, these
findings can inspire parents
and policymakers to advocate
for musical training in school
as an enjoyable and fulfilling
outlet that also has the power
to boost our brain strength
and improve reading,
writing, and arithmetic.
There are data actually that
need to be expanded upon
that all aspects of the SAT
are improved by between 20
to 30 points when comparing kids
who have had music classes
regularly throughout school
to those who have not.
So it seems that musical
training keeps our brain --
helps keep our brain
sharp as we age
and could be an integral part
of rehabilitative programs
for older adults, as well,
coping with cognitive decline.
All right.
>> Mario Rossero:
Thank you, Alex.
I think that's a
great [applause] --
starting with the evidence is
a great place to start, right.
And I know everybody in this
room, we are all interested
but also charged with
measuring the impact
and telling the stories
of our work, right.
And so often we're looking
at, you know, the intervention
in the classroom or with
kids, and we're tracking that.
But I love holding those
outcomes against the science
as well, because that seems
like that would make an
even more powerful argument.
When we were prepping
for this conversation,
Alex and I had a brief chat
about the Kennedy Center's
work with Renee Fleming.
She's got a really deep interest
in music and wellness, right.
And so we've done this
Sound Health initiative.
And a project called
Music and the Mind.
But she literally --
she had this, you know,
opera diva in an MRI singing
an aria, and they're, you know,
checking her brain
waves as this is going.
And we saw the visualization.
And the most sort
of stark outcome
to me was not when
she was singing.
It was her preparation
to be creative.
That's when her brain lit
up with the most activity,
the preparation to
create, which I thought was
so interesting, right.
And it really resonates once
you think about it, because it's
that -- it's -- you're
getting ready.
Your brain is getting ready.
You're preparing for
that moment of creation
or that act of making, right.
Really exciting.
So thank you for
starting us off.
So we also -- you know, on
this panel we have experts
from different art forms.
So we know that every art
form really makes an impact
on students.
And we all sort of
find at least one,
but maybe sometimes
multiple ways
to express ourselves
and to communicate.
So Christopher --
>> Christopher K. Morgan: Yes?
>> Mario Rossero: -- I'd
like to turn to you next.
I would love to hear a
little bit about Dance Place
and the role in the community.
And then just sort of talk
about your work and how it fits
into this conversation.
>> Christopher K.
Morgan: Absolutely.
Aloha, everyone.
My name is Christopher.
My sign name was given to me
by some Polish deaf
students 20 years ago,
so this is my sign name.
My pronouns are he and his.
And as a native Hawaiian, it's
important for me to connect
to my ancestors and bring
things into this space.
So I want to recognize that
we're on colonized land
that was stolen hundreds of
years ago from native tribes.
And also to brig my
ancestors into the room.
I offer you this.
It's very non-secular.
It's about the meeting of twos,
land and sea, sky and water.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Aloha, probably the only
Hawaiian word you know.
[Speaking in foreign language]
And that's the foundation
of equity, recognizing
as many things
as I can sense in one moment.
And that's the foundation
of bridging to youth
and just people in general.
And so for me, you know,
the dance person always has
to get a little interactive.
I'd love to ask for you
just sitting in your chair
to point -- when you
think of the future or --
yeah, I'm just going to leave
it at that, the future --
would you point toward
the future for me?
Nice, I love arts people.
It's always a more mixed
answer than if I were
in like a corporate environment.
Can you do that one more time?
I just want a better survey.
Try and keep the same answer,
if you don't mind,
that you did before.
Point toward the future.
Okay, oh, and someone
made a dance out of it.
It's not static.
It's moving.
So great, just anecdotally,
what I tended
to see was forward and up.
And so one of the gifts
that dance has given me is
peripheral vision, right?
If I'm dancing with people in
a line like the Rockettes --
okay, I've never been a
Rockette, but I dreamed of it.
If I'm dancing with
people in a line,
I have to use my peripheral
vision to sense that we're,
if it's needed, in unison.
And we use that all the
time as laypeople in driving
and other daily skills.
But one of the things that
I think is interesting
in some cultures, the future
is neither forward or up.
It's back here, because
you can't see it yet.
It has not been revealed
to you yet.
However, there is so much that
we have as humans, our senses,
our intuition, or
instinct, our gut --
in Hawaiian it's [speaking
in foreign language] --
that allow us to
sense the unseen.
And for me, a lot about equity
and access is trying
to tune into that.
How do we sense -- and
sense is so related
to the word sensitive
-- how are we sensitive
to the needs of others?
Words we use a lot in our work
as arts educators,
arts advocates.
How do we do that?
How do we connect to that?
And so much of that is about
tuning in and listening,
and all art forms are
really good at that.
And that's why so much of that
evidence about how it spans
out into other aspects of
our lives, the scientific,
the educational data, all
of those things pay off,
because it's allowing
us to tune into others.
So a little bit about
Dance Place.
I'm the Executive Artistic
Director of Dance Place.
It's based here in Washington,
D.C. It's a 37-year-old
institution.
And we've been in our location
in Brookland/Edgewood
for 31 years.
Our Founding Director
Carla Perlo
and her Co-Director Deborah
Riley recently retired,
and I became the Director
after a national search
for a new director just
this past September.
So I'm pretty new to this role.
Obviously, I'm not
new to the arts.
But Dance Place, in addition
to being a presenting theater
that hosts over 45 weekends
of performances each year
from international,
national, and area companies,
and having a school, and having
youth enrichment programs,
has been an anchor
in our neighborhood.
When Carla and her board at the
time bought their building in --
31 years ago, it became
kind of a galvanizing force
for that neighborhood.
And we all recognize
the problems
that come with gentrification.
We've been pretty fortunate
in the Brookland/Edgewood
neighborhood
because of a history
of high home ownership
in that neighborhood, and as
well as some pockets of land
that were empty, a lot of
the development that happened
in the last five to 10 years
in particular didn't
displace too many people.
I fear and think it might
be coming in the future
as development increases.
But to-date, it hasn't
been too jarring.
So what's happened in
our neighborhood is
that our community has continued
to mix both economically,
racially, and in all kind
of definitions of diversity.
So that's presented Dance Place
with some wonderful
opportunities
in our different programs
to engage the community,
to bring them in, and see
what happens as a third space.
What can we do when we
bring these different
communities together?
When Carla and the
original Dance Place staff
and faculty were there 31 years
ago, couple of youth knocked
on the door, and they just
needed a place to hang
out until their parents
got home,
and they needed a bathroom.
It was a little cold outside.
That literally became
the foundation
for our Energizers program.
Our Energizers program serves
youth between six and 12,
as well as our Junior
Staff program.
Our Junior Staff manager
is here today, Naomi.
Hi. Thank you.
She was not expecting that.
And so these programs
are offering life skills
and arts curriculum to
help empower these youth,
just like a lot of the
work that you all do does
and give them a good place
to be and some good skills.
That program expands
every summer to 75 kids
from about the 25 that we
serve during the school year.
And those kids get five weeks
of programming throughout
the day that's based
on a similar curriculum.
And then our Junior
Staff program,
they work with us
throughout the year.
They have different jobs and
roles within the community
at Dance Place and
on our arts campus.
So this is how -- what our
programming looks like.
But as I just started this
work, I'm really interested
in thinking a little bit more
about this mixed neighborhood
that we're in and the
challenges that it presents.
I literally had some
teenage boys yell at me
when I asked them to leave
our arts park at 9:30 p.m.
because our building was closed,
and it was time to go home.
And they yelled at
me, "You're new here.
You don't know what
it's like here."
And I hear that.
I recognize that, and
I understand that.
And at the same time, how do
we create an environment that's
embracing of them, and
embracing of these challenges,
and also trying to get them to
anchor themselves and go home
at night when that's
appropriate?
I -- you know, and there's a lot
of reasons why I don't want them
out on the street at night.
It's not necessarily
just for what they do.
It's for what might
happen to them.
So these are the challenges
that we're facing there.
And how can we continue to
bridge our curriculum in ways
that bring those different
socioeconomic groups together?
I've anecdotally noticed in
our tuition-based program,
which grew to be serving about
500 youth in the last two years
from about 300 just
two years ago,
that most of our tuition-based
programs racially look a certain
way because of new
communities that have moved
into that neighborhood.
And our Youth Enrichment
programs racially look a
different way.
And so how do we curricularly
start to bridge that
and create a foundation
for their futures
that recognizes how incredibly
mixed our world is that we live
in and provide tools
within which in one
or two sentences they
can recognize the history
of where we are, the
diversity in the room,
and how hopefully we can
sense one another sensitively.
>> Mario Rossero: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Christopher, you make
me really think --
I mean, I think this already,
but you, I think, articulated it
in a very special way which
is, you know, arts education --
I'm always a champion of working
from an asset model, right.
And so the struggle -- instead
of like, "Oh, woe is me,
the struggles that we have,"
think about the power
that we have.
And so I think uniquely
arts education,
among other subjects -- we
think about literacy, math,
etcetera -- arts education
is really so well-poised both
out of necessity, but out of
its ability to not just be
about curriculum and
instruction, right.
Not just about what you learn
in the artform, but isn't it
about listening, right?
Isn't it about community?
Isn't it about bringing
things together, right,
recognizing past,
present, future?
It has the ability to do
all these things and sort
of knit them together in
a way that I think really,
especially within a school,
within a neighborhood,
within a program, it's got
this sort of superpower, right,
this ability to bring
all these perspectives
and things together.
And I don't know that
everyone looks at the sort
of other curricular
areas in the same way.
So I appreciate your
articulation of that.
So Nathan -- I've known
Nathan for a little while.
We both were in Chicago Public
Schools fighting the good fight
in arts education.
I think we're the
two visual artists --
>> Nathan Diamond: Yeah.
>> Mario Rossero: -- up here.
So Nathan leads the
charge in the team
at D.C. Public Schools
for arts education.
So I know you've got some
particular initiatives
that we're going to dive into,
but I thought you might
just take a moment to sort
of continue the conversation and
talk about the work of equity
and access in your role
and with your team,
and then transition us
to your specific program.
>> Nathan Diamond: Absolutely.
So as Mario said, I'm
the Director of Arts
for D.C. Public Schools.
So in that role, I oversee
curriculum and instruction
across the district and across
all disciplines in the arts.
He also mentioned
I'm a visual artist.
My background is in photography,
and design, and printmaking.
But I am actually going to talk
about a music initiative today.
And so that should be --
>> Mario Rossero:
I'm just trying
to represent all artforms.
>> Nathan Diamond:
Absolutely, absolutely.
And it -- you know, it's
been great to listen
from Dr. Chu's remarks
all through about the idea
of how we approach the
arts as a language.
This is a real challenge,
I think, in education --
in the education sector
because literacy has very
specific connotations.
And we are really pushing in
my office to broaden the scope
of what we talk about when
we talk about literacy
in public education, expanding
that into visual literacy
and music literacy.
And so the role, I think -- you
know, this idea of equity --
these three words,
equity, access,
innovation could not be
more kind of gift-wrapped
for the work that
we're doing right now
because Chancellor
Wilson, the new Chancellor
of D.C. Public Schools, has a
really intense focus on equity
and how we are approaching
our schools for what they need
and what the communities need,
not just sort of even strokes.
But what actually do we
need to give each student
and each school so that young
people can be successful
in D.C. Public Schools?
And for us in the arts, that
comes in a few different forms.
It's about exposure
and opportunity.
And I think those are things
that sort of everybody
in this room really
addresses quite frequently.
But I think bigger
than that, what we look
at is how are we empowering
students to use their voice?
And so we talk a lot about
the use of a student's voice.
And how do we transition from
a skills acquisition model
where we area sort of
building students' capacity
up to do certain things
as they get older?
And more, how are we
handing them these tools,
giving them space to use
them, to experiment with them,
to understand them on their own
terms, and then guiding them
from there as they get older?
And so it is really about
how we are being strategic
in that process from
pre-K through 12th grade.
I think critical is, you know,
literacy in the traditional
form is always
about how do we get students
to express themselves?
How can they write
their ideas down?
How can they speak eloquently?
How can we be sure that they
can sort of operate in society?
But as we know, the arts
do that incredibly well,
and they reach students who
are challenged to be reached
by traditional forms
of literacy.
And so one of the things
that we hold dear is
that if we are not equitably
-- equity and access --
if we are not equitably
reaching all of our students,
there are voices
missing from our culture.
There are voices
missing from our society.
And if we know -- which we do --
that a lot of the issues
of success in schools --
as Christopher was
talking about,
even in the way he
sees differences
in his populations -- we know
there are a lot of things
that fall along socioeconomic
lines.
And so it is clear to us --
we can look at the research
and know the groups of voices
that are actually missing
from our culture that
aren't being expressed.
And so to us the arts
is such a critical place
where we have the potential
to start that change.
And Dr. Chu spoke about
that eloquently earlier.
So how we're doing this, we have
-- three years ago when I --
three and a half years ago
when I came into this role,
I was asked to really look
at what the curriculum
of DCPS arts is and how
do we write a curriculum
for the future?
And so to Mario's point, the
arts don't live comfortably
in the world of curriculum
and instruction the way
traditional content areas do.
This has a lot to do with
the way we evaluate and test.
You guys know.
>> Mario Rossero: Choir.
>> Nathan Diamond: Yes, exactly.
And so what we set about doing
was changing what a curriculum
looks like, can it both meet
the needs of a district --
can it look like what a
district needs it to look like,
but also realistically
communicate what it is
that actually happens
in an arts classroom?
What value the arts add
to a student's life?
And so we created what's called
the Framework for Arts Learning
which is rooted in six themes.
And those themes span
from pre-K through 12,
and they are universal
themes that we
as human beings explore
throughout our lives, identity,
interaction, language,
determination,
creation, and transformation.
It is those six words
that anchor all
of the work that we do.
And the idea is that while
those are incredibly complex
and deep things that
we all struggle
with throughout our lives, if we
can start young people looking
at those things developmentally
as a five-year-old
that we are giving
them the opportunity
to really explore what it means
to be human and what they would
like to discover and understand.
>> Can you say those again?
>> Nathan Diamond: I certainly
can, identity, interaction,
language, determination,
transformation --
I'm sorry, creation,
and transformation.
The tricky part about
this is those are --
these are very lofty goals.
And the question always comes
back to but how does that get
to a student who
is five years old?
Do we start talking to
them about transformation?
And so I think what that
looks like then is we
as the adults are putting
these sort of larger concepts
of development at the
forefront of our planning,
but that doesn't mean that we
aren't also bringing skills
development and structure to a
young person to get them there.
So it is really about how
we are being intentional
that by the time a student
leaves D.C. Public Schools we
want them to understand
what those concepts mean.
But we don't start there.
We start there in our thinking,
but not with young people.
What it means for young
people is that when they are
in an arts classroom, the
first thing they should feel is
that what they are doing is
meaningful and matters to them,
that it is connected to
their life, that they feel
that they have a place
in what is happening.
That's our entry point.
We need to get them
engaged in what's going on.
From there we can -- it's --
you know, when you have somebody
who is engaged and ready to
learn, it is much easier to say,
"Let's build some skills.
Let's have some kind of
intentional instruction,"
because now there's a
desire for that instruction.
And then I think the most
critical thing that we infuse
into every piece
of curricular work
that we do is students
must have an opportunity --
I call it playtime.
Technically, I don't
call it playtime.
That's what we call it.
What I call it is like their
opportunity to experiment,
to come to terms with the new
things that we are asking them
to come to terms with before --
this is the really
important part --
before we decide to judge
them, before we assess them,
before we grade them, before
we say, "This is high-stakes."
We give them that space
to play so that we
as educators can watch and
understand where they are,
where their learning is, and
make sure that they have --
back to that equity piece --
they have what they need to
be successful as individuals.
And then lastly,
I think they're --
you know, in that
assessment role, in that time
when we're really looking
at how far can you take this
as a young person, we ask them
to use those skills
in unique situations.
We pose unique problems and
ask them to use those skills
to solve those problems.
So what this looks
like in practice --
I said I was going to get to
an initiative about music,
which I am -- is a program
that we launched at the start
of this year called D.C. Keys.
D.C. Keys.
>> Keys?
>> Nathan Diamond:
Keys, piano keys.
And so this came from an
earlier idea that I had --
that I was working on in Chicago
and then brought here was
about a middle school initiative
to begin ideas of
music production.
How do we not just involve
kids in traditional ensembles,
but how do we get them involved
in the idea of production
and digital production.
And how do we start to bridge
the relationships between what's
in their headphones and what
happens in their music class?
Which both in my role in
Chicago and my role here,
there was a really
large disconnect
between those two worlds.
And so how do we start
to create bridges?
And to me the first step in
that was starting to look
at how the music that
they are listening
to is actually produced.
Like how do you start
to get involved
in that creative process?
It was an early process,
and a --
like I said, it grew out
of something in Chicago,
but it really --
I'm a visual artist.
This is not my -- what I would
call my native discipline.
And so it wasn't until two
years ago when I was hiring
for a music position, and
ray Muller who's -- he's --
I'm going to have somebody wave
to Ray Muller over there --
who came in, and in
his interview the --
what he said to me
changed everything.
He said, "We need to teach
kids that music is a language.
It is not something
to be repeated.
And they are not just there
to play something that's
already been written.
It is there for them to write."
And so I hired him.
And then I was telling
him about this initiative
that I had been working
on that was struggling --
admittedly struggling.
And he said, "Well, we shouldn't
start in middle school.
We should start in
kindergarten."
>> Yeah.
>> Nathan Diamond:
And that was it.
Like that -- you know,
it was that instantaneous
[applause] -- absolutely.
It solved so many
problems that I --
you know, that I
was struggling with,
but that I hadn't
identified which was, one,
music will be a language.
We'll just start it
from the beginning,
so it will be no different.
That's just how it
will always be taught.
To how do we make sure that all
of our students have
instrumental instruction
which is incredibly
costly, and there's a reason
that it often lives in high
socioeconomic neighborhoods.
But in D.C. now we can say with
12 keyboards in every school
which means the keyboards
that we have,
24 students can be
playing at any one time.
All of our elementary students,
25,000 kids, are learning
to play the piano as we speak.
>> Wow.
>> [Applause] And so it solves
that issue of are we ensuring
that our young people are
learning an instrument
and learning to perform?
And the last piece is
that it bridges the world
of analog and digital.
Right, it bridges
the traditional
and the contemporary.
The keyboard is the one
that both lives like a piano
but can be plugged
into a computer.
And so then we can
start this process,
which the curriculum is rooted
in composition and
improvisation.
So our students,
starting in kindergarten,
at the end of every
year will compose.
You know, we need to shift our
ideas of what composition means,
right, that it's a whole new
definition of composition.
But we are asking them to use
music as a language every year
that they are in
music education.
The big headline of that, the
piece that matters most to me,
is that as a system we
are creating young people
who see themselves as
creative producers of culture,
not just consumers of
culture, which is, I think,
also a big shift in
what we're doing.
We're not just trying to make an
audience for later on in life.
We're actually trying
to make the people
who create culture
later on in life.
And we don't do this
on our own, either.
I think critical
to this process is
that we have worked very closely
with Washington Performing Arts,
many of whom are here
in the audience today,
as partners to engage kind of
the broader music community
and to have access to things
that as just a public school
system we don't have access to.
And so they have supported
us in this process.
They have worked
with our teachers.
And they have stepped up to
say that they will be there
when we figure out what it is
we actually need from them,
which I think is
even more important.
It's sort of like the blank
check side of it, which is like,
"We are here for you, and
you know what it is that" --
you just call.
To the point where at --
this year they have actually
changed their capital arts
programs to meet the needs
of our new curriculum.
With an organization that works
in so many of our schools,
that's a critical relationship
that we have, that we can start
to mold how the two
organizations work together.
So to wrap up, I really
want you to hear this.
And so I have a student here
with us, Jose Andre Montano
who is from School Without
Walls at Francis-Stevens.
He is a sixth-grader there.
He is a jazz pianist.
He is a composer.
He is just an incredible
musician.
And he really -- his work
exemplifies what I am talking
about, which is how does music
act as an individual voice?
How do you create it so
that it is your voice?
And so I'm going to turn it
over to Jose Andre to perform
so that you can hear
what it is that drives us
in my organization to do
the work we're doing for all
of the young people in
D.C. Public Schools.
>> Mario Rossero: [Applause] All
right, let's hear it for Jose.
[ Applause ]
>> Jose Andre Montano:
Microphone?
Hello, hello.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Jose Montano.
Thank you for admitting me
into the Library of Congress,
for inviting me to play for you.
It's an honor to
play for all you.
And that I'm very happy
to be here with you.
So I wanted to show you --
I wanted to play a song
that -- I really liked it.
And to all the people that
are here, listen to me.
I wanted to show you
like how to do --
like Nathan was talking about
-- how to do like [inaudible]
and how to make a new
composition, right.
So I will show you
some music for you.
And this song is called
"In a Sentimental Mood."
Hope you enjoy it.
[ Piano Playing ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Mario Rossero:
Thank you, Jose.
We're going to actually invite
you to join us up on stage, so.
>> Jose Andre Montano:
Okay, of course.
>> Mario Rossero: While we
do that, could we get a round
of applause for Jose's mom and
dad who always support him?
[ Applause ]
>> Christopher K. Morgan: Why
don't you sit next to him?
>> Mario Rossero: Thank you.
I feel really lucky.
Jose's had a relationship
with us at the Kennedy Center
for a number of years, and I
just got to see you perform
with Renee Fleming
a couple weeks ago,
and I think he stole
all the attention.
This kid is a rock star.
We'd love to bring you into
the conversation, Jose.
And just if you could talk
a little bit about music
in your life and the
importance of it.
>> Jose Andre Montano: Okay,
music, I think, is important
for me because I think
music, it's a feeling.
It's a feeling for me, and it
brings you a lot of feelings --
it's really hard to explain,
but it's important for me
because -- for school.
It helps me improve my
education at school.
It helps me to get new
things I never got before.
And that makes me really
happy because at --
that inspires me to still
doing what I'm doing.
And as you can see, in
the song I just played,
it brings you that
feeling, right?
>> Mario Rossero: Yes.
>> Jose Andre Montano:
It has to be like --
it's really hard to explain.
>> Mario Rossero:
You're doing great.
>> Jose Andre Montano: You have
to transmit the music
while you're playing.
And then when I finish
answering your question --
when I finish answering
the whole question,
I will show you the same song,
but little bit more faster
so you can see the difference
how you can transmit a little
bit more better your music.
So yeah.
>> Mario Rossero: Great,
and I wonder if you might --
I know you write songs
on your own, you compose.
Is there one that you're working
on now or a new title of one
that you're working on?
>> Jose Andre Montano: Oh, yeah.
I already have some
compositions.
And a couple days ago
-- like on Friday --
yeah, on Friday I composed a
new composition that it's called
"For My Friend Collin."
It's for my friend from school
that is one of my best friends.
And a couple days ago
I composed a song,
but it's a surprise for him.
>> Mario Rossero:
Okay, great, awesome.
Well, we won't ask any more so
that it can stay a surprise.
Jose, I'm hoping that
you'll stay with us onstage
for a few minutes, and maybe we
can end with your next piece,
if you're going to show
us another way to do it?
>> Jose Andre Montano: Yep.
>> Mario Rossero:
So a few minutes
of patience would be great.
I'm going to --
>> Jose Andre Montano:
That's all right.
>> Mario Rossero: Thank
you, because to your right,
we have Asha who has
been patiently waiting.
I'm so glad you joined us, Asha
Gardner from Split This Rock.
And Asha, we'd love to hear
you jump into the conversation.
We know you are born and
raised in D.C., right?
>> Asha Gardner: Mm-hmm.
>> Mario Rossero: Spoken word
is a big part of your life?
>> Asha Gardner: Yes.
>> Mario Rossero:
And you kind of grew
up through the program --
>> Asha Gardner: Yes.
>> Mario Rosser: -- as
well as working in it now,
so welcome to the conversation.
>> Asha Gardner: Okay, hi, guys.
So I'm Asha Gardner.
I do work with Split This Rock.
I am a product of Split This
Rock nonprofit organization.
For the past seven
years, since I was 15 --
I'll let you guys do the
math yourselves, you know --
I've been working in
arts programs with youth,
worked all over the city with --
I don't know -- Split This Rock.
I started off in high
school, you know.
In high school, you
go to this wild place
where it's like, "I
know what I think.
I know what I want.
I know what I need.
And I have to voice it," right.
But in schools there can be
a very definite structure
as to how one can
present those needs,
or how one can communicate
their feelings,
or tell your teacher
what you went
through at home the
other day, you know.
And I felt for a while that --
felt like there was
this like disconnect.
You know, I felt like my
school had counselors.
My school had deans of students.
My school had vice principals.
But there was no language
to use between us that would
like effectively get my
point across, you know,
to let them know that, you
know, "My heart hurts today.
And I'm sorry I'm not paying
attention as much," you know.
And I found a really great
sponsor in my building.
She was actually the
librarian, that was as my mom,
so that's why she was like the
best person in the building.
But I kind of -- I found home
in the library, you know.
And there was a space
where while I was sitting
and like looking through all
these books and everything,
this space where I could be
like, "I trust you, you know.
You're an adult in this
building I can trust,
like aside from the fact
that, you know, we're related.
Could you please like, you
know, listen to me talk
about the things I'm going
through just for a second?
You know, with my
friends and other things?"
You know, she would
listen to me all the time,
but she would always in the
conversation be like, "You know,
this is not what I'm here for.
You know, I'm a librarian.
You know, this is what
I'm supposed to be doing."
And she challenged me one
day, and she was like, "Well,
start a club, you know.
You and all your friends come
here, and you sit around,
and you talk about all your
problems, and you cry together,
and you laugh together.
So why not make it a
real club, you know?"
And we were like, "Wow,
that's a really great concept.
What kind of club can
we start to like talk
about our emotions and things?"
And you know, this
over -- I don't know --
the spirit of art
was in the building
because Split This Rock
was making their rounds,
and opening up their new youth
programming with D.C. Slam Team,
and bringing back all of their
big movements in the city.
And she offered us this
opportunity to be like,
"Start your own poetry
club," you know.
And I was like, "What
are poetry clubs?"
You know, I'm thinking like
Shakespeare, and Robert Frost,
and like Emily Dickenson sitting
around together like, "Heh, heh,
heh, this is so cool," you know.
And I really like not,
you know, entertained.
And honestly, it
didn't seem like a --
you know, what we were
trying to get around to.
It felt limiting, you know.
>> Mario Rossero: Yes.
>> Asha Gardner: And this idea
of spoken word poetry
came about, right.
And she brought these
artists to the building
to present their program to us,
to kind of like give
us a buy-in,
like this is why you
should house our program.
And there was an
artist, Rasheed Copeland.
And he came in, and he did this
amazing poem about his sister.
And I watched myself, my
friends -- we were theater kids,
so you can -- we're a little
giggly and a little like,
you know, we can't sit still.
We can't help ourselves.
And for that three minutes --
his poem was no longer than
three minutes -- we were stuck.
You know, we were
encapsulated in his world.
We were feeling his emotions.
We understood his
relationship with his sister
by the end of the poem.
And we sat around together --
more so me, because I kind
of dragged all my friends
into this poetry
club business --
and we were kind of
like, "We can do this."
And at the time in our
high school as, you know,
minority students over in
Woodrow Wilson Senior High
School, there wasn't
a big place for us
in our musical theater program.
It was unfortunate,
but we had --
we felt like we had
all of this art in us
and no place to put it out.
And we were like, "Spoken
word sounds like nothing
but monologues to me, you know.
This sounds like something
I can do, you know."
And personally, I was
jazz-trained in singing.
A lot of my friends
were trained in singing.
And we found all these places
where all these different art
forms can meet in lyricism --
simply lyricism, you know.
Call it spoken word, call
it poetry, call it rap,
call it what you may, you know.
But it's this spoken form of
expression, you know, that says,
"This is what I'm feeling, and
this is what it feels like.
And let me let you feel
it, too," you know.
So we started this poetry club,
and spoken word was our thing.
We taught ourselves how
to do spoken word poetry,
and we prided ourselves,
you know,
in how far we had come with it.
And this new era --
this new lane opened up.
It went from spoken
word poetry --
so we went from poetry
on the page, Shakespeare,
all that good stuff, to like
this cool like modern twist
on it, you know, more vocal,
more, you know, active,
to this competitive part, right.
Mind you, we're theater kids.
We don't do sports.
We don't have a sports team that
we can like fit into, you know.
So we're like, "Competition,
you say?"
You know, and so slam
poetry came into play.
And what slam poetry is is
basically -- I don't know --
individual students, groups
of students, teams, whatever,
get together in a community
setting like an open mic,
but instead of everyone just
going up onstage and just,
you know, delivering their
emotions or their pieces,
we add a little bit
of points to it.
You know, we say how much
effort did you put into it?
Did you really believe
the words that you said?
Have I heard that poem before?
You know, little -- all
these things start to matter,
you know, and we start to
hold ourselves accountable
for the artists that we're
building ourselves into.
And we liked that challenge.
You know, we felt
we had been waiting
for that challenge
for a very long time.
So Split This Rock started,
the Louder Than a
Bomb DMV competition.
Louder Than a Bomb was
actually a competition started
out in Chicago amongst
Chicago city public schools.
And it created this cool
place for all the kids
from different areas
of the city, right.
So if you can imagine, for D.C.
it would be something like --
well, what it is something
like is people from Southeast,
Northeast, Northwest, you
know, everyone coming together
for a weekend -- one weekend.
So every high school being
present, every demographic,
every corner, ever thought
and belief, every walk of life
from your city is
present, you know.
And they're all in your
age range, you know.
And you guys are
expressing yourselves,
exchanging your thoughts,
and how --
what your view is on your
life, you know, in the city.
And you guys look around like,
"Wow, we're not so much --
you know, we're not as different
as we thought we were."
And we have elders --
I call them elders --
the teachers, the sponsors.
To be given that
term with respect
because you guys
harness an environment.
You guys are responsible for
this environment, you know,
where students come, and
they are very vulnerable,
and they are exposing a very
large part of themselves
that in most cases if they
didn't have art would be silent,
you know, would never be brought
to the surface, you know.
And you guys are delegating,
you know, and helping them,
and holding their hands,
and letting them know, "Hey,
I saw a kid who did
a poem like yours.
I think you might like them.
Go check them out," you know.
And look, there's a bond --
a cross-town bond
started you know,
turns into a friendship
that lasts forever.
So kind of talk more on
what I feel like, you know,
arts brings -- arts programming,
it's this opportunity, you know,
for students to apply, to
challenge themselves, you know,
to try community, you know, step
outside of their comfort zone,
because I like to
think that a lot
of times artists aren't
always the most --
I don't want to say
normal people, you know.
We aren't always -- we don't
always like fit in all the time.
And that can be very --
you know, it can put you
in a very isolated place.
It can be socially
traumatic to a degree.
Emotionally on the long term as
you build yourself into an adult
and go down your line as --
to adulthood or whatever,
you have all of these
issues, you know,
because you never solved
your problems, you know.
And we're having this
opportunity to start solving
and addressing some of these
issues while they're fresh,
you know, and they're young.
And there are people, there are
sponsors, there are teachers,
there are program directors,
there are teaching artists
who are responsible for making
sure that that process goes
as less rocky as
possible, you know.
So what I do now is I
am a teaching artist
in these schools.
So I've gone through
the programs.
I've done the slams, and
performing, and spoken word.
And now I've seen the
opportunity to go back
and teach, you know, my
students what I know.
I felt like I made it -- I
got so many opportunities,
and I made it so far
in my personal life
by just expressing myself, you
know, by feeling these limits
of -- and bounds just fall off
of me, that I felt the need.
I don't know why.
There's a student in D.C.
who isn't in a program.
Honestly, on a realer note,
I am from D.C. I'm
third-generation Washington,
D.C., Washingtonian.
And I've grown up with
students, with young people,
with young adults from
all over this city,
from all over the
country who do have --
come from all areas of the
economic ladder, from all areas
of religions, and walks of
life, all colors of skin.
And regardless of
any of those things
or how they differentiate, one
thing we all share in common is
that it's critical
that we have something
to do with our free time.
So easy for us to
get in trouble.
It's -- I mean, not kind
of like funny trouble.
I mean, the kind of trouble
that doesn't allow us
to come home ever
again, you know.
And as a youth in the last
two years, I've had --
I've lost friends, you know,
in the streets, and around,
in front of their
homes, you know,
in front of their neighborhoods.
And I think to myself oftentimes
like if they had programs,
you know, if they had a
sponsor, if they had a mentor,
if they had somebody who
could keep their mind
and keep them busy
on something else,
would they still
be here, you know?
And so I feel that's
the severity
and that's like the demand.
And that's what we do here.
>> Mario Rossero:
Thank you for that.
[ Applause ]
I really love what you said
about the cross-town bond.
So having spent 12 years
in Chicago, I know Louder
Than a Bomb really well.
And I just -- what I want
to paint for a picture
for the room is if you
haven't been to one
of these poetry slam
competitions,
it is the most supportive house
of kids that you've ever found.
Like I've been in auditoriums of
2000 high schoolers in Chicago
from every neighborhood,
and they are only supportive
of whoever is onstage, even
though it's a competition.
And that's why I've
like adopted the --
like I use the snap all the
time, because it's a way
to show support when someone
is onstage struggling,
but also sort of -- I don't
want to call it a milder round
of applause, but it's
like a low hum of support
that you can let people know
that you've got their back.
>> Asha Gardner: Well, so
snaps are like a cool thing.
So when you're -- someone is
onstage, and they're performing,
right, and you get really moved,
because that's what we aim
to do is like move you
guys out of your seats
and like, "Oh, my God.
That was great!"
It's like -- it's kind
of disrespectful to step
up in someone's home and
be like, "Oh, my God!
That was so awesome!
I"-- and they're still,
you know, talking.
So we have this thing
in our communities.
We have these little
mannerisms we do to --
so we let people know that
like, "You are appreciated.
You are being received.
I am listening."
So snapping is one thing
we do, you know, the snap.
Another thing, if you're
ever in a poetry area,
you can do like a
sweet chocolate noise.
It's like if you have the last
piece of chocolate on the bar,
you put it in your
mouth, you're like, "Mmm!
Yeah." We like the sweet
chocolateness [sic].
Also a new thing that the
community's adapted is
awkward giraffe.
So you can like throw your hand
in the air and be like, "Yes!"
You know, little things.
So there are these cool
little mannerisms we have
in the arts community that
are teaching people how
to like appreciate their
neighbors, you know,
and how to respect, you
know, someone who's speaking.
You know, all of these -- the
parts of -- I don't know --
being a citizen, you know, being
humane in the world, you know.
>> Mario Rossero:
Yeah, really lovely.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Rhona, I think we
need to find some kind
of cross-collaborative
project for us to work on,
because these guys
are such rock stars,
and I feel like we
could tackle anything.
We're going to get to a
couple Q&A in a moment.
I just -- I'm going to start
to once again knit
together this conversation,
which I think is
already really connected.
But you're hearing from, you
know, different perspectives
about really the necessity of
the arts in everyone's lives.
And I was thrilled
that Jane Chu talked
about our Any Given Child
program here in D.C.
that has really been
a work-in-progress
for many, many years.
We have a unique window of
opportunity for every sector
of the community to
come together and say,
"How do we prioritize
arts education in D.C.?"
And part of the work to do that
is to look honestly at the data
which -- and data
is a listening tour,
hearing communities,
hearing voices.
It's looking at numbers.
It's looking at maps of the
city and analyzing the gaps
and the saturation points.
And it's also looking at
research and best practice.
So it really kind of marries
these things together.
So I would urge everyone to
kind of keep that on your radar
and watch that progress,
because it's a real outcome.
It's something that's happening
right now that takes this kind
of conversation and puts it
into an actual structure.
And I think, you know, if I add
anything to this conversation,
you know, I get so
inspired, but I also laugh.
When I worked in -- I've worked
in school districts
my whole life, right.
Well, when I worked at central
office, they mostly needed me
to be the creative individual,
right, bringing a different kind
of solution to a
problem, and then put
that creativity into
a structure.
But now at a performing
arts organization,
they only need my structure.
But for those of us that are
sort of the structure-heads
in the house, that is
important, too, you know.
When I hear Nathan talk,
when I hear Asha talk
about the systems, the networks,
the role of mentors, that --
the building of those
constructs is also an artform
and really critical,
because you need all
of us working in concert, right?
So couple of minutes
for questions.
Anyone have something
that they want to direct
to the whole panel or
to somebody individual?
Feel free to raise
a hand or stand up.
>> Mario.
>> Mario Rossero: Oh, great,
so we have a couple mics.
Yes, Jenny?
So if we can get a mic to come
around to second
row in the middle.
Thank you so much.
Great.
>> Hi, so first of all,
thank you, and especially
to our youngest members of
the panel for your eloquence
and for really walking the walk.
Thank you for that.
We've talked a great deal about
teachers, about institutions,
about individual artists.
But I would love to hear what --
how you feel parents can be
more involved in the equation,
because I think many of us who
have children or have children
who are friends with children
in public schools, especially,
wonder what their role is and
how they can be really active.
And your mention of
your mom having this --
these two roles sort of reminded
me to insert that question
into the conversation.
>> Mario Rossero:
Great, thank you.
Who wants to tackle this one?
>> Asha Gardner:
Well, I don't mind.
Parents -- I think parents are a
necessary to all of the process,
to -- that they bridge
the gap between the arts
and the education, you know.
They are the story.
They are the emotion, the reason
that the kid is, you know,
expressing themselves
in the first place.
And I think the most
crucial part to that,
which we lack frequently, is
presence of those parents.
If you know your student
is involved in a program,
urge yourself -- you know, urge
your student to be, you know,
open to you being there.
You know, show up.
You know, leave them a note,
let them know that you're proud
of them just for like, you know,
preparing themselves
for the day.
There's so many ways a parent
can put a foot, a hand,
a finger, you know,
in the child's
like developmental process.
And it doesn't stop at home.
It's a constant process until
they leave the nest, you know.
And I think not just all along
the way, but with students --
I'm sorry, teachers,
I think, it's --
sometimes what we do is keep the
parents away from certain parts
of the project because
it can be scary
to have the parents around.
You never know how
they're going to react.
I've dealt with a few scary
parents already in my, you know,
teaching years, you know.
And I can, you know,
resonate with that.
It can be very terrifying,
but you have to be open --
>> Mario Rossero: That's right.
>> Asha Gardner: -- you know,
because those are the people
that made the student that you
love, and that you're watching,
and who's watching
over you, you know, so.
>> Mario Rossero: Yeah, I hear
really carving out that role
and including them as well.
>> Asha Gardner: Definitely.
>> Mario Rossero: Yep,
you can add to it, Alex.
>> Dr. Alexander Panteyat: I can
just share a personal example.
I'm from the Ukraine and
started lessons at age seven,
as I think I mentioned.
And for the first five years
I took lessons, my grandma was
in there every lesson writing
in a red notebook
that I still have.
>> Mario Rossero:
That's awesome!
>> Dr. Alexander Panteyat: Very
large, hard-to-read handwriting,
taking notes on what
the teacher said.
And then I was required
to review it
when I came home
and as I practiced.
So that was definitively
formative for me, and --
>> Mario Rossero: Oh, my God.
That's beautiful.
>> Dr. Alexander Panteyat:
-- feel very lucky.
>> Mario Rossero: Okay, one
more response from the panel,
and then we'll go to
our next question.
>> Christopher K. Martin:
I was just going to say,
from an institutional
standpoint,
what are the mechanisms
that we can put in place
when it's difficult
for parents to show up?
So how do we find
ways to support them?
How do we sometimes
gently require it,
because sometimes there
can also feel like arts --
after-school arts programming
can start to feel like daycare.
And there's a drop-off/pick-up
mentality.
And so institutions
like public schools
that often have sign-out
systems for young people
because of protecting them,
can we institute that so
that the parents have to come in
and, just as brief as that is,
have that point of
contact and engagement?
And then also when we start
looking at young people
that become deeply invested
in their artistic practice
and are considering
that for their futures,
how do we support them in
the tough conversations
with their parents that
sometimes are fearful
of what a future in
the arts looks like?
The future in the
arts looks like this.
It's bright, and
beautiful, and supportive.
It's not easy, but it's viable.
And so I've -- totally
understand,
my parents were not
sold on it for years.
Even when I was making
money as an artist,
they still were not sold on it.
And if I had had advocates
that helped supported
that conversation -- so we
as institutions can, I think,
partner in a lot of ways
to help smooth that,
as well as inviting
them in and trying
to get them to be present.
>> Mario Rossero: Thank you.
>> Christopher K. Martin: Yeah.
>> Mario Rossero: Great.
Another question, looks like
you're already ready over here.
>> Yes, I have two
questions, if that's okay.
And the first question
is directed
to Jane Chu if she's still here?
>> No, she's not.
>> She's not?
>> Mario Rossero: Nope.
>> Okay, well, maybe somebody
can ask here because I wanted
to know -- the first question
is I wanted to know the status
of the National Endowment
of the Arts,
because when 45 was elected, I
think he announced he was going
to get rid of the National
Endowment of the Arts.
I know I was signing
petitions to keep it,
the National Endowment
of Humanities,
the Public Broadcasting
Corporation.
If any of you can
answer that question.
The second question I
guess would be directed
to Mr. Alexander, okay, it was a
beautiful presentation you gave
on the effects of
music on the brain.
And I wanted to know if you've
done any studies on the effect
of music and the arts,
but particularly music,
on autistic children?
Not necessarily Asperger's,
but kind of in the
medium of the spectrum.
>> Mario Rossero: Great.
So I know we can
address question two,
so we're going to
focus on that one.
And maybe there can be a sidebar
after the panel with colleagues
in the audience about the second
-- or about the first one.
So Alex, you want to take that?
>> Dr. Alexander
Panteyat: Absolutely.
So there are already a number
of studies that indicated
that group music-making can be
incredibly pro-social for kids
on the autism spectrum.
And your -- the timing of your
question for me is very apt.
I am exploring a research
study at Johns Hopkins,
my institution, as we speak with
the Kennedy Krieger Institute
and several other partners.
So we have an interested
music therapist,
and we are actively
exploring that now.
Until now, my work as a movement
disorders neurologist has
focused on the other end
of the spectrum, aging.
So I've done a study called
Parkinsonics using group
choir-based singing to
improve communication --
get the voice louder and clearer
in patients with Parkinson's,
and we're submitting
that for publication
in the next few weeks.
And just to give
everybody a broader context,
I've been very fortunate
to help establish and lead
at Johns Hopkins our Center for
Music in Medicine where we seek
to make music and rhythm an
integral part of healing illness
across the age spectrum.
>> Mario Rossero: Great.
And you know, it's interesting,
performing arts organizations,
definitely across the District,
but across country also,
are really thinking about --
for performances how to
create more relaxed settings
so that whether it's an
autistic child or other barrier
to really participating
as an audience member,
that there's more
relaxed performances
that are really built
to welcome all folks in.
So unfortunately, we're just
-- we're right about at time
and we are going to
end with a performance.
So I wonder if you might
just indulge me on one second
because I always -- I'm
always fiercely taking notes
because I look for themes
from these conversations.
So usually, I end up
with like five bold words
but I have about 30 [laughter].
So I try to get them down to 10.
So this is what I'd
like to leave you
with before we leave
with another song.
So this crosstown bond, I love.
Meet in lyricism -- come on.
I think voice was just
across this whole panel.
Evidence, ancestors,
language, tools, literacy,
producers of culture, trust.
And then I love -- I
think this was Asha --
finding a home in the library
which I think we
did today, right?
So can we do a beautiful
round of applause
for this wonderful
panel, please?
[ Applause ]
And we'd like to give a
thunderous round of applause
for Jose who's going to
play one more piece for us.
So thanks again.
[ Applause ]
>> [Inaudible] with the mic.
>> Jose Andre Montano:
Hey again.
I'm back.
>> Mario Rossero:
All right [laughter]!
>> Jose Andre Montano: Okay,
so I would play one
more piece for you.
It's one of my compositions
actually.
>> Mario Rossero: Great.
>> Jose Andre Montano: So this
one is called [Inaudible].
Hope you enjoy it.
[ Music ]
>> All right!
[ Applause ]
>> Mario Rossero:
Thank you, Jose.
>> Jose Andre Montano:
Okay, before I say --
before I say bye to everybody
-- before I'm leaving,
I will give a quick message
to everybody that is here.
This -- it's a really
important message.
And it's going to help you and
it's going to change your life.
So this -- be brave always.
When you are scared,
it's not going to help
and you're not going to do a
lot of things in your life.
You always have to
practice, rehearse,
be good with the
people and be brave.
The birth and the music
is very important for you
because it's going to -- it's
going to help you to get a lot
of things and it's going
to help you to your life
because maybe you're going
to have some challenges
and that important things
is going to help you to get
that challenge out of your way.
So stay with this phrase.
Be good. Be brave.
Brave -- sorry.
And rehearse all.
God bless you and thank
you very much to everyone.
>> Mario Rossero: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Lee Ann Potter:
So we're going to --
>> Mario Rossero: Thank you.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
Thank you again, Jose.
Marvelous!
So we're going to take about a
30-minute pause but I don't want
to call it like a break-break
because when Sue was speaking
earlier and enticing you a bit
about all of the treasures
and magical things that are
in the collections of
the Library of Congress,
we have a few of them next door.
So in the room right next
door, colleagues of ours
from the American Folk
Life Center which is part
of the Library of Congress,
as well as our Music Division,
as well as our Prints and
Photographs Division --
they brought some examples
of the Library's
artistic collections.
And I really, really hope you
will take some time to stop
by next door, take a look.
The restrooms are right
around the corner near
where you came in.
And please be back in
your seats right at 11:30
so that we can get our
second panel started.
Thanks.
>> Rhona Wolfe Friedman:
Now, we're just about ready
to start with Panel Two.
But before we begin,
I just wanted
to acknowledge the former Chair
of the Arts Commission,
Anne Ashmore-Hudson.
Can you just say hi?
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
It was through Anne that
the Arts Education policy
that we started 10 years
ago came to fruition.
So thank you.
And now, without further
ado, we will start Panel Two.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
Okay, hello again.
You always hope that
after coffee
and stretch time,
folks come back.
So thank you for coming back.
Appreciate it.
So I'm Lee Ann Potter.
I direct Educational Outreach
here at the Library of Congress.
And a couple of months
ago when Rhona
and I started brainstorming,
what this symposium would do --
we agreed that it should answer
essentially four questions.
Well, maybe three questions.
I'll get to the fourth.
We thought about why.
We thought about how.
We thought about what.
We thought about all
those good questions.
And as far as the why
goes, what we were thinking
about was why Arts
Education matters.
And I think our first panel
certainly did an excellent
addressing the why.
Our hope with regard to
the what was that some
of you would be thinking,
"What does the Library
of Congress have to do
with Arts Education?"
It's not immediately
the first place we think
of when we think of the arts.
So our hope was that when
you had a chance to see some
of the items from the
Library's collection and hear
from Sue earlier about what else
is in the Library's collection
that the what does the
Library of Congress have to do
with Arts Education would
become much more clear.
I hope that happened.
By the way, did any of you
happen to see anything next door
that you weren't
expecting to see?
Good, that was kind of the hope
that you'd see some things you
hadn't expected would be here.
The next question is
really the question
that our second panel is going
to focus on this morning.
And that question is the how.
So how do these amazing
resources that live
in the collections of the
Library of Congress --
how can they be incorporated
into Arts Education in ways
that are truly meaningful
and truly inspiring?
And so we have a marvelous
panel and I'm going to start
by introducing you to
a colleague of mine.
Ray White is a senior
music specialist
in the Library's Music Division.
And he is actually -- you know,
when I say that this is a panel,
I got to be honest with you.
It's really not so much a
panel as it is a performance,
a panel and a performance.
So our first performer
is my colleague Ray White
and Ray is going to do
a performance for you
that I hope will get you
thinking much the way a
classroom teacher
is often thinking
about how do we get young
people to understand
that creativity doesn't
just happen,
that it really is a process.
And that rough drafts really
do play an important role
in creativity.
So with that, and that's all
I'm going to say about that.
So Ray, it's your turn.
[ Applause ]
>> Raymond A. White:
Thank you very much.
What I'm going to offer
up in the next few minutes
are materials that are housed
in the Library's Music Division.
And they're among
our great treasures.
And they do demonstrate the
creative process at work.
Now, perhaps many of you may
be familiar with the song,
"My Favorite Things" from
the Sound of Music .
And perhaps the sound that runs
in your brain when you hear
that is Julie Andrews
singing it.
But suppose she sang this
which Oscar Hammerstein wrote
before he wrote what you
probably remember.
[ Music ]
[ Laughter ]
Oscar Hammerstein was on
his way where he was going
but he was not there
yet [laughter].
Also from the same show,
there's the famous song called
"Do Re Mi" and Oscar started out
with this idea that he was going
to find some word to make each
of those syllables
into a phrase.
And this was before
he quite arrived.
[ Music ]
[ Laughter ]
You sort of have
to figure out that
when you get so -- it's sewing.
We [inaudible] -- I don't know,
who would necessarily
have thought of that.
Now we shift gears to Irving
Berlin whose materials also
reside here at the Library.
And one of the things
that his materials for
"God Bless America" demonstrate
that depending on the time
and circumstances of
someone's creativity,
their creative product may vary.
Now the short story about
"God Bless America" is
that it was originally written
during the closing months
of World War I.
It was part of an
all-soldiers revue called Yip,
Yip Yaphank which was at Camp
Upton at Yaphank, Long Island.
And this was going to be
the last song in the show.
So he wrote this thing
called "God Bless America."
Well, he ultimately decided
it was too anthem-like
to be the end of this vaudeville
show so he put it aside
and he came back to it
in 1938 and revised it
when circumstances had changed.
But this is what he first wrote.
[ Music ]
Now, okay in 1918, the
idea of left and right
as political orientations
were not in common parlance.
And all he meant was guide her
to the right path which is fine
but guide her to the right
of the light from above.
And then he decided 20 years
later when he was fixing it up,
it became "Guide her through
the night with the light
from above," which is just
plainly better poetry.
So there went that change
but the song keeps on going.
And it continues like this.
[ Music ]
Now, the part you were running
in your head was probably the
mountains and the prairies
and the oceans white with foam.
Well, that didn't
exist in the early one.
Make her victorious because
the United States was
in a war at the time.
But on land and foam [laughter]
-- foam has to rhyme with home.
I get that part.
But then he in 1938, went
back in the mountains
and the prairies and the
oceans white with foam.
Okay, that's an acceptable line.
And -- but then -- so we
got the foam and the home
and then he finishes
up with this end
which I find a little
bit musically awkward,
dare I say it.
Ready?
[ Music ]
Now, I would say again, I
don't think there's anything
at all wrong with writing
something that's clumsy
or awkward or inelegant or
whatever you want to say
in the creative process as long
as the creative process
continues along [laughter].
And it gets where it's
ultimately going to go
which points out to me
that music writing is
part art and part craft.
And our last example is
also from Irving Berlin,
his 1946 show, Annie,
Get Your Gun .
Now if you met -- if you've ever
seen that show or know anything
about it, you know it's
about Annie Oakley,
the 19th century sharpshooter
and her friends Buffalo Bill
and Charlie and Frank Butler
and they want to get her
to join the Western Show.
So these three guys sing this
song, "There's No Business
Like Show Business" telling
her how great show business is.
And so as the song goes on
and the verses progress then
she kind of joins in with them.
And then when they
get to the reprise,
she sings it all herself,
"There's no business
like show business.
Let's go on with the show."
Well, there were a lot of
words that Irving Berlin wrote
for this song that didn't make
it to the final stage either.
And bear in mind that the
ones that we're going to share
with you now are
in that category.
Before we do though, I would
like to introduce my colleague,
Stephen Yusko, who has joined us
at the piano for
this performance.
Thank you, Steve.
[ Applause ]
So imagine, if you
will, these three guys
and then Ethel Merman
belting out,
"There's No Business
Like Show Business."
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Oh,
that was marvelous.
Thank you, Ray.
Terrific! So our
next two panelists
and I'm going to
kind of this way.
Our next two panelists represent
organizations that are part
of the Teaching with
Primary Sources Consortium.
And for more than 10 years,
the Library of Congress has
been receiving appropriations
from Congress that have been
directed to the Library for us
to redistribute as
grants to organizations
to develop curriculum
and to make available
professional development
opportunities for teachers.
Today, we have 29
different organizations all
around the United States who
are receiving grant funding
from the Library with
all kinds of programs.
Not all of them are specifically
connected to Arts Education
but two of the programs that
are represented here today are.
Erin Elman is going to
be our first speaker.
And Erin is currently the
Dean of Continuing Studies
at the University of the
Arts in Philadelphia.
And I'm going to let
Erin take it from here.
>> Erin Elman: Okay, oh.
So I'm going to actually do
a little bit of a PowerPoint.
How do I move this?
Just -- [inaudible], okay.
Move it over here.
Hello, everyone.
>> Hi.
>> Erin Elman: I want to just
say how inspired I have been
and Ray, that was a really
tough act to follow [laughter].
I don't sing.
I'm a visual artist.
But I'll just start up by saying
that I am really
honored to be here.
I'm going to -- I've been so
inspired by the first panel
that I think I'm
going to shift things
up a little bit in
my presentation.
So I may not get through
all the slides but I think
that you'll enjoy it more.
So just to give you a context
of who we are at the University
of the Arts, we're in
Philadelphia, Pennsylvania.
We are a small private art
institution that houses all
of the arts -- visual,
performing and creative writing.
We're actually the only
university in the nation
to devote ourselves
exclusively to the arts.
There are 1800 students
that are studying graduate
and undergraduate programs.
And I represent the Dean
of Continuing Studies,
so what's that?
That's another 2900 students
that are the learning continuum
from very young people that
do out-of-school programs
on Saturdays and credit-bearing
programs in the summer
for high school students.
We also have enrichment
programs for adults.
But we also have about a
thousand in-service K-12
teachers that come to
us to study programs.
The Summer Music
Studies Program --
which Johanna actually teaches
in -- is part of that program.
And we also have a Professional
Institute for Educators
and those two, the music program
and the professional institute
programs, we have non-matric
and matric courses
for educators.
And so in that program
is the Teaching
with Primary Sources Program.
And just to give you a
little bit of a history --
back in 2010, we saw an
RFP for an organization
to deliver opportunities
to develop curriculum
and professional development
experiences for K-12 teachers.
And my colleagues saw
it and said, "Anne,
we have to apply for that.
We're just perfect."
And I said, "Yes, but
we're really at capacity.
How much more can we
do with 2500 students?"
And she said, "But
how can we not?"
And I said, "How can we not?"
And so we were thrilled
when we're selected
to be part of a consortium.
And what was really
exciting to learn was
that the other consortium
members which were
from across the United
States working in a lot
of different disciplines,
a lot of them history,
actually they themselves had
requested an arts-based partner
because nobody in the consortium
was doing work in the arts.
And they thought that
was really important.
So you can -- I just -- this is
when we start [inaudible]
a little bit talking
about what we heard before
and so when Christopher said,
you know, to think
about the future,
a lot of cultures
think about the past.
We actually adapted as our
logo, "Look back, see further"
for our work with teaching
with primary sources
because we really -- that
was sort of what emerged
when we're trying to think
about how do we encapsulate
this work that we're doing?
And so, really we set about
creating a comprehensive program
where we can help educators, K
through 12 and service teachers
and librarians, really figure
out how they can bring the
arts into their teaching.
And for us, it was a little
bit of a journey as well.
So where we stand right
now, what we've developed
and we give you an overview and
I'm going to sort of break it
down a little bit, is
that we offer courses.
They're available for
free for non-credit.
We also offer three
graduate credits.
And our matriculated students
can also take these programs.
And we have two different types
of courses which I'll break
down a little bit later
which is an overview course
and discipline-specific courses.
We also create some
curriculum guides that come
out of our professional
development.
We test them and we develop
through our professional
development.
And we're going to have some
examples of those on tables
when you leave so if you want to
grab one, you're welcome to it.
We also try to provide
everything as much
as what we do online for
free to a national audience.
And so we have two vehicles
for our web presence
which I'll talk about later.
And then we have a coaching
program which I want
to mention now because I'm going
to mention the coaches
throughout the program.
So one of the things
and it's really --
and thinking really
to be thoughtful
about how these programs
live and build and grow,
the consortium and the
Library of Congress decided
that it was really important
to develop high level educators
that are really embedded
in these materials
so that they could bring
them back to their schools
and their school districts
and the language we developed
around them is coaches.
And so we have people
who take numerous courses
that we then put them
through their own professional
development experience so that
they can then become leaders
in the field.
So here's where I'm going to
go back to the previous panel.
So why the arts as
primary sources?
So thank you, panel one, for so
beautifully illustrating that.
So I'm thinking -- I'm taking
notes during the first panel.
So of course, Susan and
Dr. Chu really talked
about how important the arts are
and actually noted
some key studies.
But also, you know, Mario
talked about the arts
as a superpower like
I loved that.
Well, I'm going to use that.
And that they have
their own language.
And then, you know, Asha talked
about how as a young person,
the arts was how she
connected through school.
And we also, I mean,
thank you so much, Nathan,
for those six themes
because I think
that those themes are actually
embedded in the work that we do.
And it was the way that you
articulated them really maybe
will help us focus a little
bit more in the future.
And of course,
those performances show us how
we can be transformed and moved
through the arts and
we're all having our own
personal experience.
And so that's what
we're trying to do.
We're trying to say to
teachers across disciplines
so it's important to note that
I think that maybe some people
when we talk -- when I
talk about this program,
people think, "Oh, only art
teachers take your courses."
Well actually, no.
We have lots of elementary
school teachers.
We get gym teachers
that take our program.
We get librarians.
We get discipline-specific
teachers.
So I'd say about 40%
of our participants
in our program are arts
teachers but I guess,
what's really important is that
they get to hear the perspective
of the other teachers
about how disconnected
and siloed the arts can feel.
And they get an opportunity
to understand how they can
bring history or science or math
into their classrooms.
And so, we and the other
thing that we've learned
as we've grown in our program
is that in the beginning,
we started to think
about primary sources
in the arts as the products.
But what we actually would --
Ray just illustrated is
that it's actually the
stuff behind the scenes
that can teach us a lot
more about the arts.
So we can look at, you
know, choreographic notes
that the Library has a
beautiful collection of
or musical notation or notes
from a dramateur or sketchbooks
or notes of an artist.
And so those are all the reasons
why we think it's important.
So the way that we
developed our program is
that we have two
different types of courses
and I've listed these here.
I'm not going to
go through them.
I'm hoping that the PowerPoint
will be made available later
so that people can
go back to it.
But we have these
overview courses
and these discipline-specific
courses.
And the overview
courses generally are
about 40 to 45 [inaudible].
It depends and they're very
field trip and lecture-based.
We don't do that much hands on.
We do a little bit.
And then the discipline-specific
course is do more
of a focused study
in the discipline.
So I'm just going to just
talk a little bit first
about our overview of courses.
So in those courses
-- oh, by the way --
all of our courses run five
days, Monday through Friday,
about 8:30 in the morning
until about 6:00 at night.
They're super packed
and energizing.
We get teachers from
across the country,
people from San Francisco,
people -- because they're free,
sometimes teachers will
use it as an opportunity
to get to Philadelphia.
We can help them find, you
know, low-cost accommodations.
But we spend the first day
really introducing primary
sources and copyright
and why is it important
to teach the primary sources.
And I think what
we were surprised
to learn is how many people
that take our classes
don't actually know
about the digitized collections
of the Library of Congress
in any subject matter, let alone
the Library, let alone the arts.
So that's really sort of
an opportunity for them
to get comfortable
with their searches
and understands a little
bit about the framework.
Then we also talk about
this wonderful tool which is
in the guides that we're handing
out and online in our website.
And we're -- it's
sort of this --
a framework for observe,
question and reflect.
And it walks you through it.
And there's one specifically
for prints and photographs
but there's more general
ones and we use that.
We use that as an examples
and we have some --
always have great lecturers
come in that talk about the arts
and primary sources and
make those connections.
And you know, we're in
Philadelphia so there is no lack
of amazing collections.
And we utilize as many
of them as possible.
Then we ask our teachers
to share out and they post
so there's an opportunity for
them to do their own reflection.
And then they create primary
source sets through one
of the Library of Congress
tools which I'll talk
about a little bit later
which they can utilize later.
So very briefly, this was a
course we developed last summer.
So how many of you
have heard of STEAM?
Okay, yeah, I got the
right audience here.
So I don't have to
tell you what it is.
So we decided to say, "Well,
what kind of STEAM objects,
collateral art products are
available to the Library
of Congress that can be tied
to all different disciplines?"
And so we were so lucky.
How many of you know
that the Library
of Congress actually has
teachers in residence?
See, they do.
And they're great.
And one of the past ones
is Trey Smith who was --
he has a science focus.
And I met him while I was
here at the Library for one
of my consortium meetings.
And I said, "Well, okay.
We'll have to work with him."
So he did a presentation
and it was wonderful.
And he did some analysis
on and he really --
even though he's a scientist,
he was able to find
examples of STEAM objects.
And then we invited in --
we talked about teaching
artists today and so we invited
in two teaching artists
who came in.
One was Ben [Inaudible].
You could see his
image on your left.
I think that's right.
Yup. He's a muralist but he
works with science and STEAM
as motivation for
students kindergarten
through 12th grade
to think about ideas.
He's had exhibitions
in Washington, DC.
He's worked with NASA.
And he came in and talked about
his practice and his work.
And then we also had another
teaching artist named Aster
[Inaudible] who not only
talked about her work
but she actually did a
project with teachers.
And then we also
brought in an artist
who brought us to her studio.
So this artist, Diane
Burko, was fascinating.
For 35 years, she's
been flying all
over the world photographing
climate change.
She was really ahead
of her time.
And she's taken those
photographs and turned them
into prints and paintings
and she lectures.
She's been invited to the White
House to talk about her work.
And so we had all these artists
in as we also visited lots
of primary source locations
as we keep visiting the
Library's collection online.
And so that's an example of
one of our overview courses.
I won't talk about this one
because it's not
very [inaudible].
It's just a little
plug, if anyone wants
to join us this year,
we're developing another new
overview course called City
as the Primary Source and we're
looking at urban planning,
architecture and cartography.
And we're reaching out to
people across those disciplines
to develop that curriculum.
In our discipline-specific
courses, we do a deep dive in.
So again, it's five days.
And what that looks like is that
first day is that, you know,
what's a primary source?
How do we use it?
What's online?
What's in the collection?
What's really different
about this class is
that the participants will
actually study one particular
discipline and they will
actually create studio projects
in that discipline.
So it's important to
note, they're not artists.
And so they're drawing
or painting
or screen printing
for the first time.
And so the idea is that
they're doing projects
that they could model
with their students
who may not have comfort
in those disciplines.
And then on day five, they
actually develop a lesson plan.
They share it out.
And we have an exhibition.
So two courses that you can
grab these educator guides.
They both have guides.
One was photography and identity
so identity was mentioned today
as an important factor
for art making.
And we have, we used
the first library,
one of the first libraries in
America, the Library Company
as a place to look at
real early photographs.
And then they actually create --
so that middle image
are a portrait.
They're daguerreotype images
that they make themselves
in their class.
And then on the left side
is the Library of Congress
and the Library Company image.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Okay, Erin.
You've got about a minute.
>> Erin Elman: Yeah, okay.
So just -- I'm just going
to go quickly and say
that we also create
these guides.
And I really -- I didn't --
I brought 50 of each of them
so maybe if you want
to grab one,
they're available free online.
So you could download them
or you could contact us.
But these are materials that
you could see an example of it.
They go through the exercise
of analyzing primary sources.
And we have our web presence.
So I think just to conclude,
what I wanted to say was
that this is an important
moment and preaching
to the choir is important
for two reasons.
One is that it lets us be agents
of sharing with our colleagues
and our co-workers that may not
have access to some language
and vocabulary around
what we all do.
But it also gives
us some resources
to do what we do a
little bit differently.
So thank you all and I was
very proud to be here today.
[ Applause ]
>> Lee Ann Potter: So I
mentioned the Art Teaching
with Primary Sources Consortium.
And our next speaker
comes from another one
of our consortium
member organizations
and that is the National
Association --
or excuse me, I've got
the NAFNE in my head.
You know how acronyms
do that to you?
Yeah. So anyway, Johanna Siebert
is here today to talk with us
about a really special project
involving the new national
standards for music that were
recently developed by NAfME.
>> Johanna Siebert:
Thank you, sure.
Excuse me, the National
Association
for Music Education [laughter].
We're encouraged
to say N-A-F-M-E.
Because you know, you just think
NAfME could certainly be used
in a lot of ways, couldn't it?
So I will slip back and forth
between the two, I
think, as I talk.
You know, so but thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for having
us here today.
I'm the project director
for this project
that you're going
to hear about today.
And let's get used
to this a moment.
Here we go.
And so, in our collaboration
with the Library of Congress,
good friend, colleague
and director at NAfME,
Lynn Tuttle, wrote a proposal.
And you can see on the screens,
pretty much about what
it is we wanted to do
through the largesse
of the grants available
to us through the TPS here.
And so looking at this
three-year program we just
completed in this past
summer, units of study,
curricular units,
not a curriculum itself
[inaudible] course
in general music.
Right now, I mean, as we
speak, I'm receiving emails
with draft units for
a band and orchestra
and [Inaudible] is writing them.
And on the third year, we'll
be looking at composition
and theory as well
as popular music
and how we can access
the multiple resources
that we actually
just got done looking
at as well as many, many more.
Behind the whole idea of these
new national standards is the
idea of building student
artistic literacy.
We've heard that
word this morning
and many of you were nodding.
Many of the things that have
been said already have just
really validated the standards
and the collaboration we now
have here at the Library.
This idea of music literacy
and for children is huge.
It's not just knowing about
music but it's about being
in the music or on
any other art form.
And so as we think about all
of these, we still know we have
to keep bringing in all that
knowledge and skills in the past
because as we heard this
morning, there is a lot
of skill base especially
in music
and let it be taught
sequentially.
So we can't lose that.
And kind of, that's what a lot
of our teachers are
very comfortable with.
So as we've been
working on these,
we've kind of been
learning as we go.
As we see this shift to a
process-based literacy piece,
you're looking at the four major
processes that we talked about.
We heard about creating and
how there are steps to this.
And we heard about
composing and improvising
and [inaudible] arranging.
Whether we're talking
to pre-K level --
sure, switch the order
of opening routines
or if we're talking about
those college-bound seniors
who are going to major in
music, what are all the things
that they would be doing?
We talked about performing
which to music,
it's what we're known for.
It's what we do.
They're responding as our
focus area for this unit
but we also heard this
morning about another process
and how important personal
connections from students
through the arts to other arts
to other areas in our lives
and to other disciplines
are supremely important.
So to show you all of the things
that we need to think about,
we have five separate
sets of standards
within this new arts standards.
And so we talk about
general music from pre-K
up through Grade Eight, grade
by grade with successive ideals
of what we believe literacy
would look like in those grades.
Traditional and emerging
ensembles, those big chorus,
those bands, orchestras
and [inaudible] --
all of the different kinds of
ensembles you can think of.
We talk about comp and theory
or composition and theory,
the writing and analyzing
of music.
Harmonizing instruments --
that's making the bridge between
student's music of their lives
and student music that they're
playing in school, you know,
via guitars, ukuleles,
keyboards,
other harmonizing pieces.
And of course, bringing
in music technology.
As these were rolled out in
2014 and continued to be now,
we found that teachers
really needed
to have some extra resources.
So during that period and even
as I say, up to this date,
we are focusing at NAfME
on how we can help that.
In order to understand
a little bit,
I'm walking you very
briefly through our standards
because it would just
take another three days.
But you can see laid
out here, the processes
that we are talking about
creating is just that.
And starting at their pre-K
level, would be a kind
of writing or talking
that I heard
about this morning is
exactly what we need.
And having students be able
to go through those four steps
in an order is often
how we make sure
that they are writing,
they're refining.
When students perform,
they do just that.
We hope they're analyzing
and interpreting the music
they choose to perform.
Okay, they rehearse and
evaluate it themselves
and refine what they do
so that they are ready
for the last day to
present it, okay.
Of course, with the facilitation
of a teacher and then guided
by the teacher but eventually
taking this process on.
And the responding is a little
bit different even though the
little [inaudible]
looked the same.
These components talk a lot
about how students respond
to the selection, analysis,
interpretation and evaluation
of other people's music --
whether it's music that they're
listening to in a performance
or another composer's music, not
necessarily what they're going
to create themselves
as performers.
What you see across
the bottom is the walk
that talks about connecting.
We talk about how we relate to
things and how we interrelate
to things through
music for students.
So you've seen really the
whole gamut of what we have
and how using these,
we hope are going
to help us develop students
into that music literate
performer and thinker.
Well, as we focus on responding,
the idea is that if we
help students understand
and evaluate how the
arts convey meaning.
And we can see here the
definitions of what it looks
like in those [inaudible]
not necessarily successive
or linear components.
But the ideal again is
how do we get to this?
What are the things that
we're using for this?
The problem that we've
had is that in ensembles,
in harmonizing music
in some classrooms,
they don't lend themselves
to the study of responding.
And we need to find ways to make
that happen for our teachers.
[Inaudible] say heavily
based on skills, instruction,
development, maintenance
and all of those things.
And so where does the talk time
come to and respond to music?
If the goal of a class
is to perform something,
where are they basing that on?
So how do we help teachers find
this time to realize by focusing
on responding, we can help
them all be better performers?
And as we think about
assessment in any field,
[inaudible] course this
morning, I think of 120 students
in a course I used to observe as
a music supervisor and I think,
okay, how are you knowing
what each one knows?
So how can we get to that after
some of the responding too?
These are typical
problems that we've had.
Again, through working with the
resources here from the Library
of Congress, we're
working to be able
to take the responding
components that we've looked at
and now, after students have
responded and had the chance
and the opportunity to
listen deeply and to think
about how music came to
be written and performed,
now apply that in your
performing strand, if you will,
so that students
are relying on --
I like to call reference points.
You know, as I go to
interpret a piece of music, oh,
this is how so-and-so
interpreted that.
And now I have these in my head.
It is their toolbox
that I can draw upon.
So by using the mission
statement of the Library
of Congress, we find that these
two fit very well together.
By addressing the learning
and knowledge and history
and the relevance of all
of what we've been talking
about this morning and
seeing in the room next door
and throughout the building,
we target at how students use
that creatively and how they
use it also in performing,
composition and analysis.
The [inaudible] writing
teams has been in this way.
We've looked at music
through [inaudible]
through the past year so
we have units in those.
We have units at [inaudible]
in the five levels you see.
Those are gradually
progressing levels.
We don't necessarily
focus on a grade level
because those ensembles
don't meet that way.
They often [inaudible] choirs
or as a ninth-grade band
or as an ensemble that's all
built on audition students.
And it can look very different
from one district in the country
to another, from urban to rural
to suburban settings,
[inaudible].
Using the responding
standards, we've been able
to guide instruction via the
inquiry models that are part
of our grant proposal and using
that through the
Library of Congress.
We have our own essential
questions embedded
within the national
standards as well as
and during understandings.
So I'll talk to you and
make sure you keep me
on my time, okay?
>> Lee Ann Potter: I must
say, you're getting close.
>> Johanna Siebert:
Getting close?
Real close, working on it here.
So this is one of the
grade two units, okay.
It takes about our objectives
through I can statements
because this is what students
and schools are using
throughout the country.
This is a dance unit
or a movement unit.
So the essential questions, how
are music and movement alike?
How -- why does music
make me move or dance?
And you can see our performance
standards listed as well.
So this opening activity
that a teacher would lead
would be reviewing some skills
and how do we move?
What are different ways to move?
She would -- excuse me,
extend it by asking them
to add new movements
to the piece --
a sense of think
about how they walk.
And again, in vocabulary ready
for students at that age.
The opening activity and
Jan's going to help me
in the back, right, Jan?
I like it.
By clicking on one of
the jukebox recordings
that she used as
an introduction.
So thanks, Jan, go ahead.
[ Music ]
Good, thank you, Jan.
So we'll keep it short
so you can hear that.
But you can imagine second
graders reacting to that.
Sometimes, we should be the
one reacting to that [laughter]
at the same time what
that would be like.
And you could see
also and I'm going
to [inaudible] to click ahead.
I'm looking -- they lead back
to -- thank you very much.
Okay, the questions that she's
asking through various types
of prompting and inquiry,
kind of those things.
And she was using a
visual thinking model.
In chorus, it looks a little
bit different because in chorus,
we talk a lot about
what could this be like?
So this intermediate level
now, for the most part,
it's usually middle
school students.
It depends on when they
start chorus in the district
like yours or somewhere else.
And so all of the units there
focus on multiple things
so at this level, we focus on
folk music and we just saw a lot
of materials next
door about that.
At the high school level,
they all focused on spirituals
so that we know students will
be singing spiritual sometimes
throughout their
high school career.
They use the Socratic
[Inaudible] Model.
Okay and then it
includes outside work.
I'm not going to
click on the link now
because I think what I'm
going to make sure is
that you have access
to this PowerPoint
and that would be
embedded for you.
So I think what we're
showing you is
that through what we talk about,
these processes become
interdependent much
as literacy is dependent upon
many other things as well.
So as we look at the
processes you see here, okay,
we know to truly
build understanding
that we want students to be able
to transfer what they've learned
to new situations and new
learnings and experiences
so that their learning
continues to grow.
It shows us more and more the
rigor of what we can accomplish
by going through stages like
this and connecting some
of those responding artifacts,
lessons that in turn
will help students focus
on their own performance
and make all their
ensemble work even stronger.
We piloted the units and you
can see on the screen that one
of these we were worried
about was that time
that this would take in
choruses and live ensembles.
And the person's
testament here talked
about how she could fit these
right into her daily routine.
And the unit showed that.
It showed how music [inaudible]
that the students loved it.
And one of the comments they
made, you will understand
because you just heard
the run-run-run example.
They often talked about like
in that old school music sound
thinking that's how we all
learned music were through
scratchy recordings.
Everything so a little discovery
that gets taught too
at the same time.
These units we've made
available to everybody.
Much as my [inaudible]
it's just talking
about having people
enroll in those courses.
We recently presented our
grade eight general music unit
at the National Social
Studies Conference.
I've asked a colleague
who was presenting with me
and we were meeting
in a poster session
and she's got a little
notebook out and she was saying,
"What else would you like?"
I don't know, well.
She started to take down
requests for different periods
of time that a Social Studies
teacher wanted units on so
that they could connect
it to music
because they knew that's how
students would learn and listen.
And they were doing it already.
So I guess we have a
few more things to think
about [laughter] this next third
year as we start writing these.
The units are available at that
website or just go to nafme.org
and watch the headers
that go by and click on it
and you'll see the
curricular units
that you can link on and use.
Anybody can use these.
You don't need to be
member nor a music teacher.
So I hope you do, okay.
I guess we'll wait for
questions for a little while.
So I hope to hear from you.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Lee Ann Potter: Excuse me.
Thank you, Johanna.
Both of those projects,
at U Arts
and with the National
Association for Music Education,
you guys are doing such
important work and reaching
so many teachers, emphasizing
that the Library's collections,
as you all know, come in
a wide variety of media.
I'm really glad you played that
part from the National Jukebox.
I'm just curious.
How many of you know
about the National Jukebox
on the Library's website that
includes historic recordings?
But now you do, see?
You know, there's
like 38 million things
on the Library's website.
>> Johanna Siebert: I
only listen [inaudible].
>> Lee Ann Potter: I am
telling you, the sheet music,
the sound recordings, really
-- I hope that after this,
you all spend some time doing
some exploring and realize
that -- and this is a
really important part,
that because this is
the Library of Congress,
this is our National Library.
All of these resources
are ours collectively.
We should be making
good use of them.
Okay, so with that, not only
can the Library's collections be
tremendous teaching tools but
the Library itself can too.
How many of you have never
spent time in the Library
at Jefferson Building?
>> I've gone [inaudible].
>> Lee Ann Potter: Okay
but some of you, all right.
So as you know, this
building that we're
in today is not the most
beautiful of the Library
of Congress buildings.
The building next door,
the Thomas Jefferson Building
is really quite extraordinary.
And our next panelist
is Kathy Tuchman.
Kathy works with our
Visitor Services Office here
at the Library and has developed
a really extraordinary tour
that's a touch history tour.
And some of you had
a chance to visit
with our little [inaudible]
in the next room to share
with you the discovery card.
And that's all I'm going to say.
Kathy, it's your turn.
>> Katharine Tuchman:
Well, thank you.
Oh, I'm just going to move my
stuff over here real quickly.
So my name is Kathy Tuchman.
I'm with Visitor Services Office
of the Library of Congress.
In this past year-and-a-half,
I've had this fantastic
opportunity to work
on two projects and a lot of you
may have been able to see some
of the projects I
was working on.
The first one is the
Explore the Building Cart
which we had earlier.
The Visitor Services
received this fantastic box
of original materials
that we used
in our construction
of the building.
My colleague, Megan White and
I worked on this cart together.
We went from researching
everything
from how bricks were made to how
the pouring methods of granite
and marble so that --
that way we could interact
and have all the answers or
try to have some of the answers
at least for our visitors.
What is the Cart Program,
you might want to know.
The Cart Program is a way for
visitors to come to the building
and interact with us in
a totally different way
where they can get hands
on, feel the original pieces
of the building and
they can ask questions.
A lot of times, people come up
and tell me they were a
third-generation carver.
They wanted to share
their experiences as well.
So it's a really
fantastic experience.
Docents are trained
on the cart material.
They have gone through
a training program.
They have a wonderful manual and
so we're there to support them.
The other project that
I was lucky to work
on this past year was
their Touch History Program
which is our tour for the
blind and visually impaired.
We at the Visitors Services
have fantastic tours.
We offer constituent public
reserved tours throughout
the day.
Our docents go through
a 10-hours-a-week,
15-week training program
for a total of 150 hours.
And with that is just
to share with you
that this is a well-developed,
well-researched tour.
It's not just drawn
together quickly.
The docents that are chosen
to do Touch History have been
docents for at least one year.
They are not completely
new to the program.
The Touch History, we enhanced
verbally our normal tour.
So we give great history.
That's similar but then we go
into more descriptive ability
with the building, give
people an opportunity.
We also reached out to the
architect of the Capitol
and let them know that we
were working on this project.
And they were incredibly
generous with us.
We have the best.
And so many of you saw.
I have an original brick here.
A lot of people don't know
that the Jefferson Building
really is a brick building --
22 million bricks went to the
construction of this building.
But you don't really see them
so people don't realize that.
So I have a brick.
You can feel it.
It's quite heavy.
The -- and also a piece of the
granite because the exterior
of the building, we have
like a cross-section.
So you have -- the
granite is on the exterior.
We have the marble -- the
brick plaster and then,
of course, the marble.
If you've been in the building,
you've seen that
we are a marble.
That is just like the icing,
like the -- on the cake there.
It's marble cladding.
And this allows visitors
when we're doing a
Touch History Tour,
I can hand these
to our visitors.
They can feel them.
They can interact with
them, feel the coolness,
the smoothness of the surface.
Depending on their visual
ability, they can maybe want
to reach up and look
at it closely.
The tour allows that
for our visitors.
The -- I want to back up a
little bit also because I want
to talk a little bit
about the ceiling.
The architecture of this
[inaudible] was fantastic.
I have some original
pieces of the marble mosaics
which I didn't bring over with
me on -- but the architect did.
If you've been in our
building, you'd see three
of our alcoves are
mosaic ceilings.
And the architect put
them on a wooden base
so that we can hand
these out when people --
let our visitors feel this.
Get a real sense of what this
-- the incredible artistic --
artistry that was involved
in doing these ceilings.
So that's just a little bit
about the why and how we did it.
We also besides working
-- I researched.
I went to a lot of museums
to see what they were
doing throughout the --
you know, in New York
and here in Washington.
We researched online to see what
best practices are the museum
world are doing in
tactile tours.
Luckily, we have a fantastic
PEO DP division here,
our equal opportunity disability
programs and we worked
with Lorena Bradford from
the National Gallery of Art
and had a wonderful
review with her.
So let me tell you about --
I told you that we
do a descriptive.
So let me -- if I can,
this is going to be fun.
Let me give you a
little bit of a tour
of going into the building.
If you've never been in our
building, this will be exciting.
So the Jefferson -- the Library
of Congress was created --
let's back up, 1800, correct?
And our first 97 years
were spent in the Capitol.
That's where we are -- we began.
Then we are -- the
Librarian at that time wanted
to see us expanding our services
and wanted a larger building.
So they -- Congress
appropriated the funds
to build the Jefferson Building.
So let's talk about
the Jefferson Building.
You walk up the grand staircase.
You come into the building,
into the first alcove
which is the Alcove of Minerva.
Minerva -- there
are four alcoves
that surround the great hall.
The first one is Minerva.
You walk in there.
There are the eight
pairs of Minerva,
goddess of wisdom
and defense of war.
From there, we walk
through the arch --
one of the three arches
into the Great Hall.
The building is fantastic
in its symmetry.
What's done on one side is
equally done on the opposite.
If it's on the left, it
will be equal on the right.
I love this building.
So we're now standing
in the Great Hall.
Let's align ourselves.
We're in Great Hall.
We hear lots of sounds.
It's really noisy.
The Great Hall is called that
because it's pretty large.
It's 50 feet across and it's
about 43 feet from front
to the next set of arches.
It's 75 feet to the ceiling.
So it's quite large.
From where we're standing,
if we were to look up,
we can see up to
the mezzanine level.
And there is a marble
banister that runs all around.
So this, the mezzanine
level is available
to us, the sound of it.
So it's quite loud.
Right and on the left-hand
side of the Great Hall,
we have the Grand Staircases.
These are fantastic.
They're about nine feet wide.
There's -- they go up
to the second level.
And of course, on the
sides of the staircase,
they could have left them plain.
But why would we do that?
This is 1897.
Why did we want to do that?
So we have these fantastic
sculptures going up the sides
and they are called putti.
A lot of people refer to
them as cherubs but putti.
And they're like little babies.
We have four and then it has
a landing and then four more.
So we have eight on the
right, eight on the left.
I'm going to talk
about four on my left
if we're in the building.
>> Do you [inaudible]?
No?
>> Katharine Tuchman: No.
That's [inaudible].
Yeah, when you're going up the
side, the putti or in little --
what I would call like a
window, like a little house.
There are four of them,
and they're aligned
up next to each other.
The first one is sitting there
on his knees facing us directly.
In his right hand he
has a rake and a hoe,
in his left hand he
has a watering can.
And we can actually see
the water coming out of it.
So he would be our what?
So our gardener, correct?
Next going up to would be
our -- he has an angle to us,
this next little [inaudible].
He would be facing the left.
His left hand is
reaching out of his house,
trying to get to the gardener.
And in his right hand, behind
him, is a butterfly net.
And he, of course,
is our entomologist.
So we're showing
with the [inaudible]
that different occupations,
different hobbies are
all represented here.
And this is a fantastic thing,
especially with kids, to come
and they can interact and
try to show them which --
you know, what do you think
this [inaudible] does?
Look at the -- look
at the clues.
But with the touch history,
I like to give a little
bit more description.
The last two, one would be,
of course, sitting there --
the last [inaudible] would be
sitting there with his book
on his lap, his head is
down, and he's studying.
He's our scholar, because we, of
course, have to have a scholar.
And last but not least on this
group would be our printer,
because where would we be at the
library without the printing.
So we have those on either
side of the building, going up,
and it's a great opportunity to
be expansive in our description
with our visitors who
have visual impairments,
and also with kids when
they come into the building,
we can bring the building
to life with them.
Last thing I want to
mention about the Great Hall.
Did I mention that you
can park about 10 cars
in the floor of our Great Hall?
That's kind of a fun
thing to mention.
Gives you a sense of the size.
Across from us, I told you about
the staircases, but directly
across from arches
that we're standing at,
we have three more arches.
And I need to mention the
two -- the middle arch,
we have the scholars, the
young and the old scholar,
those are important to mention.
They stand six feet in height.
The young scholar was
on our left hand side,
he's actually leaning
into his left arm,
he's got his left leg crossed
behind him, and he's looking off
to his right and his
paper that he's holding.
And, of course, he's learning.
And on the right hand
side is our older scholar.
And we know he's older
because has a beard,
his skin is a little bit looser.
And he has a tablet.
And of course when the building
was built they might have been
implying that the young scholar
had the newer technology,
the paper, and the older
scholar had the old technology,
it's a little tablet.
But as I like to say
to my tourists today,
that the older scholar really
has the latest technology,
correct?
[Inaudible].
But to finish a bit of our
tour -- oh, did I hit that?
To [inaudible] our tour, I would
take us to our left hand side,
out of the Great Hall, into
the Hall of the Education,
into the hall of family.
And I like to mention this hall
because this one, you come in,
it's about 70 feet
long, 20 feet wide,
and it's about 26
feet tall, about.
It's got an archway,
which is where some
of these beautiful
mosaics come in.
And our mosaics are
not only decorative,
but they also have
information in them.
In our ceiling, since this
is the hall of the family,
we have great educators.
And in 1897 the librarian,
the very first name
is Howe, H-O-W-E.
Has anybody ever heard of
Howe, Samuel Gridley Howe?
Some of us have.
Samuel Gridley Howe was
the first superintendant
of the Perkins School
for the Blind,
which is important to note.
Next to his name is
Guiadette [assumed spelling],
which was the first
superintendant
for the School for the Deaf.
So in 1897 both the blind
and the deaf were
listed in our building.
I think it's important.
There's also -- I have
to mention this alcove is the
listing of all the librarians
of Congress that we have, which
I love to mention on our tour.
And our visitors are allowed
to go up and feel this.
We're -- when the
building opened
in 1897 we had only one
woman's name in the building,
it was 1897, and that was
Sapho [assumed spelling].
As of last year we now
have a second name,
Dr. Carla Hayden is
engraved in our building,
so it's really fantastic.
So I hope you enjoyed
my little brief tour,
and the wonderful opportunities
that we have to engage
with visitors in a
whole different way.
And if you didn't get to see the
cart, it's -- we still have it.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Lee Ann Potter:
Thank you, Kathy.
So the Thomas Jefferson building
that Kathy has been telling you
about welcomes about 1.5
million visitors a year.
And a few thousand of those
visitors make their way
into our Young Readers
Center, which is also a part
of the Library of Congress.
And every Friday
morning at 10:30,
if you want to see something
pretty spectacular, you can come
to infant and toddler story
time at the Library of Congress.
And it's unlike any
other program
that happens here
at the Library.
And you might say it's
a little bit louder,
and some might describe as
being a little more chaotic.
But late this summer,
early this fall,
I was over in our Young Readers
Center, and my colleague,
Sasha Dowdy, and our
intern at the time,
Erin Durham [assumed
spelling], who is a student
at the University of
Maryland, they were practicing
for the upcoming story time.
And, you know, story time
always involves songs,
and there's always a
little bit of movement.
But this was the first story
time that we were experimenting
with bringing some musical
instruments into story time.
And it was really
quite something.
When you're used to see
a little bit of chaos,
and suddenly a violin
is involved,
three year olds are mesmerized.
And so I thought it
would be kind of fun
to mesmerize you guys
for a little bit today,
and so I invited Sasha,
and I invited Erin to come
and share a little bit of
musical story time with you.
>> Hello. Thank you, Lee Ann.
All right.
So this book that
we're presenting
to you today is called Mole
Music by David McPhail.
[ Music ]
Mole lived all alone
underground.
He spent his days
digging tunnels.
[ Music ]
At night he at his
supper in front
of TV and then went to bed.
[ Music ]
Mole liked his life, but
lately he had begun to feel
that there was something
missing.
[ Music ]
One night on the television
a man played the violin.
He made the most beautiful
music mole had ever heard.
[ Music ]
I want to make beautiful music,
too, Mole said to himself.
[ Music ]
So the next day he sent away
for a violin of his own.
[ Music ]
Every day Mole checked
his mailbox.
[ Music ]
No violin.
Finally, after nearly
three weeks, it arrived.
[ Music ]
Mole was so excited!
He picked up the violin and
drew the bow across the strings.
[ Music ]
But instead of beautiful music,
all he made was a
horrible screeching sound.
[ Music ]
Mole tried again.
The violin still screeched,
but not quite so horribly.
Mole kept at it.
After about a week he
could play one note.
[ Music ]
Then two.
And before a month went by,
he could play an entire scale.
[ Music ]
Mole continued to practice.
He learned to put the notes
together in a simple song.
[ Music ]
Years went by.
Mole got better and better.
[ Music ]
He was happier than
he had ever been.
During the day as he dug tunnels
Mole hummed the music he would
play at night.
[ Music ]
Now Mole played even better
than the man he had
seen on TV so long ago.
[ Music ]
Sometimes he wondered
what it would be
like to play his
music for people.
[ Music ]
He imagined himself playing
before a huge audience.
[ Music ]
He imagined that he played
for presidents and queens.
[ Music ]
He even imagined that
his music could reach
into people's hearts, and melt
away their anger and sadness.
[ Music ]
Why maybe his music could
even change the world.
[ Music ]
Mole laughed at himself.
How silly I am, he thought,
imagining that my music
could do all that,
when no one has ever
even heard it.
[ Music ]
Mole played one more song.
Then he put down his
violin and went to sleep
and dreamed beautiful
peaceful dreams.
[ Music ]
The end.
[ Applause ]
>> Lee Ann Potter: So we have
about three and a half minutes
for questions [laughter].
You guys are fabulous.
That was just great.
Don't you want to
come to story time?
>> Yes.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Okay.
It does look like we've
got a question over here.
[Inaudible] got a mic for you.
>> Hi. Hi everybody.
Thank you so very much.
This was a wonderful panel.
Just a wonderful day, really.
Question for you all, this is a
question that we've been talking
about as a community very
recently, what does it mean
to be a national organization
serving local audience?
Maybe some of you
could illustrate a bit
of how you're working
specifically with D.C.,
family engagement,
empowerment, you know,
today's conversation is about
equity, access and empowerment.
How are you as [inaudible]
organizations empowering young
students and their families
to take full advantage
and incorporate the
amazing amenities
and offerings here,
nationally, to D.C.?
>> Lee Ann Potter:
Great question.
And actually, I'm very
happy that you asked it.
So story time that happens here
at the Library is not something
that we live stream,
it's not something
that we make a big deal out of.
And like I said, one of
the reasons why I wanted
to invite Sasha and
Erin to do this
for this particular event was
to really stretch the reach
of that program, hoping that
maybe there's an opportunity
for some mimicking to go on.
I know certainly that programs
like that are happening
all over the country.
And what we want
to be doing more
of here is showcasing
some of that.
As you know, we're being
live streamed today.
And the opportunity to extend
the reach of programs here
at the Library by using
those technologies is one
of the ways we're
trying to do that.
But that balance between
figuring out, are you local --
are you serving a
local audience,
national audience?
I'm not sure it's neither/or,
I think it's a both/and.
I think there's an
opportunity to really recognize
that those local audiences,
and those -- I mean, frankly,
we have a [inaudible]
here at the Library
in our Young Readers Center.
And some of the opportunities
that we're able
to make available to those young
people, we're trying to figure
out very deliberately
how do we capture this
and make this available to
a much broader audience.
What we've done this year,
something sort of new
with that group, is
asking colleagues
from around the Library to come
to each one of their meetings
and share with students some
of the resources that are
in their collections, so that
the kids have a better sense
of the enormity of the place.
And we need to do that with
a much broader audience.
I mean, it's both.
It's both/and.
>> Katharine Tuchman: I would
say in Visitor Services we reach
out quite a bit with a
lot of our tours to invite
in the different school groups.
And when we do specific
tours in the exhibitions,
like when we had the Magna
Carta was here, we had reached
out quite a bit to a lot
of D.C. public schools
and invited them in.
And it was in docent
led tour where the --
so we do do a lot of --
>> Lee Ann Potter: Yeah, and
that million and half visitors,
you know, they're coming from --
>> Katharine Tuchman: Yes.
>> Lee Ann Potter: -- all over.
>> Katharine Tuchman: Yeah.
And our tours are
available to everyone.
>> Johanna Siebert: I guess
one of the things I think
about it is, you know, and again
I based a lot of what I talked
about today on the
national standards.
And how the responding units
being built from those,
you know, through resources
here were meant to connect
to students no matter where.
And so looking at things
like that, when you think
about how can teachers
personalize it,
either to perhaps a
culture of a community,
if you're looking
for specific music's.
If you're looking for
intercultural types
of activities, too, how can
that teacher take either
the responding units we're
providing, or through
the different processes
that I mentioned and make
that just a little more
appropriate, perhaps.
And, again, by the
levels, you know,
where do we bring our parents
in so that [inaudible] some
of our visiting artists.
When they bring in things and
talk about the music's at home.
So I would suggest that
they're meant to be interpreted
so very widely when they were
written, the standards that is,
it was meant to reflect a
national look, which is hard
to do in a document, isn't
it, because we look different
from one state and look
[inaudible] to the next.
But then how do we go
about personalizing
them would be the goal.
So perhaps --
>> Erin Elman: And I
think for us it's really
that we do attract educators
from across the country
to our programs that are
all summer intensives,
they happen in July.
But the guides are meant to
be brought back to communities
and to people who don't
have the opportunity
to come study with us.
And what we're hoping
to do is encourage them
to not only explore the Library
of Congress's collection,
but to then find ways in
their own communities,
because no matter where you live
there's a historical society,
or there's a cultural
center or museum.
And a lot of museums do
have materials that they --
what we find is that when we
tell people we're bringing
educators, they're
so over the moon.
A lot of cultural institutions
don't know how to engage
with educators, but they
have curriculum and materials
and methods, they
just don't know how
to like sort of publicize that.
And so we're encouraging
educators
from across the country
to engage
with the cultural institutions
in their own communities,
as well in using what we
know is on the Library
of Congress website is a
springboard to then replicate
that in their own communities.
>> Lee Ann Potter: That's good.
That's good.
Any other questions?
All right, then.
[Inaudible] we could use some
tap dancing, and, you know.
And I'll start by simply
saying, thank you all.
Thank you all for coming today.
Our hope is that the
conversations will continue,
that some of you will
stick around and have lunch
over in our cafeteria and visit
with each other and trade cards
and come up with approaches
that you might -- yeah, great.
And there is a question.
Yay.
>> So I just [inaudible] say
that cultural organizations
are struggling [inaudible]
with teachers and that you all
have some program or something
to help with that
[inaudible] that --
>> Erin Elman: Well, we don't
have any specific resources
exactly to connect with
cultural organizations.
What we have is a guide of how
you can find materials that work
with particular curricular
areas.
But we also have our
website, which have resources
and lesson plans, and you can
call and connect with the people
that are on our team that can
actually give you some prompt
and tell you how to walk into a
cultural organization and say,
this is what my curriculum
is, whatever I'm teaching,
what do you have in
your collections.
And we give you some tools to
start with what's on the Library
of Congress collection, so
that you know what's there.
And then you could say, well,
what can my students look
at that might be relevant
to our own community?
>> Okay.
>> Lee Ann Potter: That's good.
That's good.
>> Can I just add onto that?
Sorry. [Inaudible] --
>> Erin Elman: Yeah.
>> So -- yes, thank you.
I just wanted to add onto that,
especially when we're talking
about equity and access, and how
educators can benefit from all
of these tools, but
then actually take them
down to the local level.
The D.C. Collaborative has been
working with Nathan Diamond
and the D.C. Arts team for
some time to find ways how we
in the private sector, all
the cultural institutions here
in the District that are
serving D.C. students,
can make curricular connections
to that arts education framework
Nathan was talking about.
So D.C. Collaborative members,
through our Arts and Humanities
for Every Student
field trip program,
and as well as after
school programming and out
of school time programming that
they provide are now looking
at those -- for curricular
alignment.
So -- and we do professional
development opportunities.
And I would absolutely
welcome a field trip for us
to come up to Philadelphia --
>> Please do.
>> -- to learn best practices,
so that we can share that out
with educators here
in the District.
Thank you.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Okay.
So once again, thank you
all for coming this morning.
Thank you for the conversations
that you've started
and the conversations
that you will continue.
I also want you to
-- yes, I will.
Thank you.
Good suggestion.
It's like Julia works
here [laughter].
She's reminding me that after
lunch I ought to really head
over to the Thomas
Jefferson building.
Now that you have it visualized,
you should go see
it, if you haven't.
Good suggestion.
I also want to do a shout
out to some of my colleagues
who have been really incredibly
helpful in the planning
of this event, and in the
execution of this event today.
So Michael Appledorf [assumed
spelling], I don't know
if he's still around, or Colena
Black [assumed spelling],
and Vivian Awumai [assumed
spelling], and our teacher
in resident, Matt Poth
[assumed spelling].
And I know Deanna Bella
[assumed spelling] is around,
and Steven Wesson
[assumed spelling],
and Phoebe Coleman [assumed
spelling], thank you all.
Thank you all for being here
and for all that you did
to help contribute to today.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, Rhona.
My goal for this
was that everybody
in the room would know a little
bit more about the Library
of Congress then you knew when
you got here this morning.
And that you might start
thinking of some ways
that your organization or
that the teachers or students
that you work with might
benefit from the Library
and it's collections in ways
you've never imagined before.
And get to know us,
because we're a lot of fun,
and we got some really
cool stuff.
>> Erin Elman: They are fun.
>> Lee Ann Potter: All right.
Very good.
Deanna?
>> Remind them that
they can [inaudible].
>> Lee Ann Potter: Oh, yes.
And on your way out you can snag
a really terrific publication
called Lyrical Legacies .
Features some amazing materials
that are also available
on the Library's website.
Everything in that
publication is online as well.
Rhona?
>> Rhona Wolfe Friedman:
Thank you.
Well, we're going
to have network --
>> Lee Ann Potter: Get a mic
or John's going to yell at you.
>> Rhona Wolfe Friedman:
Is this working?
No. Well, next --
[laughter] thank you.
Next door is the cafeteria.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
Yeah, right over here.
>> Rhona Wolfe Friedman: The
restrooms are down the hall.
And we hope you'll all
come join us for lunch --
pick up some lunch -- thank you.
Pick up some lunch and
just sit at the tables.
And anyone who wants to network
can just discuss these ideas.
Are you going to be available?
And talk to our panelists, talk
to Lee Ann, talk to myself.
And thank you, Lee Ann,
again, and Susan Vita,
for this wonderful partnership.
>> Lee Ann Potter: This is true.
Thank you.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.